foreign
well hello everybody it is a beautiful
peaceful Monday out here in Los Angeles
beautiful
clean
thank you for being here we've got a
fantastic show which is unusual for us
but I know I know it's going to come
through for you guys
uh we had uh
tropical storm over the weekend was it
was a hurricane it's a rainy day out
here in Los Angeles it was a just
chilling in Cedar Rapids the hurricane
Hillary
and um we're just chilling in Cedar
Rapids it wasn't
I think in some places it was crazy I
think like in Palm Springs in the desert
it got like absolutely flooded it did
indeed like catastrophic flooding my
grandmother lived there and they were
handing uh her like sandbags and [__] at
the fire department oh man yeah
so but but I mean here in La what we did
get a lot of rain
um it's coming down I mean there was
some there was some flooding and stuff
but overall I think everyone fared out
okay the oh the weird thing was that
there was like a pretty big earthquake
right in the middle of the storm in Ojai
which is kind of far from us I felt it a
little bit but it was a 5.0 in hohai
which is pretty significant earthquake
5.0 is when it starts to starts to feel
pretty real yeah yeah
right not like crazy yet but
it's when significant it's significant
enough that's like holy [__] am I gonna
die was there any damage or anything in
Ohio I didn't even read about it I think
minor I I saw some videos uh from like
security footage it looked like a decent
Shake but nothing too crazy that was so
surreal I was like wait two natural
disasters at the same time what's
happening right now to keep the earth
clean and do what they pursue storm
Quake yeah storm Quake apparently
well I was even like wait are
earthquakes more likely to happen during
a storm for some reason no that's making
any sense
here
that's like a kind of like a
a folk tale that everybody always tells
right the whole thing about earthquake
weather feels like those quick weather
never had anybody like I've never heard
what is that what is earthquake weather
like when I heard when a hurricane hits
oh for real no I don't know
I don't think it's a real thing I've
never heard of earthquake weather
but um I'll show you guys some of the
the media from it but first I want to
say this Thursday we don't have a
sponsor today so thank you to our
members
thank you and thank you to my lovely
wife
who's dropping the the Trixie collab
that everybody's been waiting for that's
right here it is on Teddy pressures
coming up this Thursday 10 a.m PST you
know what it is it's Trixie killing it
slaying it smashing it
destroying it slay Queen loving it
owning it
it's fun it's exciting steadyfresh.com
very cool
also I will say this one more time
emphatically
members it's days like today when we
have no sponsor that I thank you from
the bottom of my heart to all of our
members the joy is a privilege to sit
here before you thank you thank you and
to make content for you and to consider
you a patron of the Arts what you are
you're a patron of the Arts you are a
supporter
of the Finer Things in life
and you should feel happy and and
self-congratulatory about that fancy you
should feel fancy you should feel fancy
because listen
without the patrons of the art where
would we be probably still clacking
Stones together
so true
so thank you
and anyone that's thinking becoming a
member Now's the Time
[Applause]
because there's all kinds of great stuff
like shows on Tuesday with Moi just for
members and what do you get on that show
my social security number my birth uh my
birth certificate my routing number bank
account number
the last the four digits of my uh credit
cards uh security code
it's all happening nice please sign up
[Music]
uh yeah and other stuff like At first
access to Live show tickets but anyway
thank you guys so big uh some
announcements on that front in the next
few weeks by the way
oh good so was there any progress with
the venue you looked at I'm not going to
say the name
uh there has been there has been working
on it I'm very excited it'll be very
cool if it works out wow dude you guys
this place that we're looking at
it's gonna be really really amazing man
that's right we'll see we'll see God but
it's like what 3 000 seats approximately
give or take
because I don't want to tell you exactly
the venue it is yet
so it's 3 000 give or take
you know what I'm saying
uh all right let's take a look at the
ravages of tropical storm
Hillary
Clinton
Dylan in Cedar Rapids look at these
morons out and by the LA River was
surging
as you can imagine it doesn't happen
very often
these morons are out there getting like
this happens very often though well and
people they just follow in this people
are just non-stop falling into the river
it's crazy like you were saying the the
rescue helicopter was just going
non-stop yeah yeah
I mean look how close they are and it's
on wet slanted surface dude Bozo if you
slip in there silly woman you better
hope you're a good swimmer it is wet it
has been raining so for people that
aren't familiar with Los Angeles uh
there is a large river in Los Angeles
the Los Angeles River that actually
named aptly named uh that a long time
ago was basically channeled up
completely into a cement flood channel
that runs pretty much the whole length
of the city and
many parts of it it's slanted like this
but many other parts of it it's just
straight down like a huge open to the
air
flood Channel that's a lot of water and
every time and it's usually completely
empty because it's very dry here but
anytime that it rains it channels an
enormous amount of water and just turns
into this raging deadly Rapids and every
time it happens
people like this are falling into it it
happens every time it rains aren't you
scared don't you have any fear it's
crazy that water is moving fast like if
you've Fallen that you are [__]
unless you're a really good swimmer but
these people wearing a full suit you're
not gonna get out yeah you're gonna
drown
at least the other dude's got some like
shiny vest on you know what I mean
they can spot his body
the recovery for his family
well there it is
uh hopefully none of them died hopefully
the same thing used to happen in Ventura
where I live there was the Santa Clarita
River I think it was yeah Santa Clara
River Santa Clara yeah yeah it was right
in my backyard
and during that crazy El Nino year it
would it was crazy it flooded all the
way into Oxnard and people were were
falling into that [__]
they're just falling into rivers
that's like the most self-inflicted
disaster that there can be it often
times is there's accidents happen but
um
uh let's see rainfall totals
how do we end up doing here
pretty good
I was wondering the total rainfall I
like what
8.5 inches in Mount Wilson yep dude
that's a lot insane
that's just in one day
I think this is for the entirety of the
storm so it's a I think it's a little
over Beverly Hills
Bel Air yeah I mean damn the the rain
was four inches
there it was good rain man got some good
rain out here
man got us some good man
um
he has a beautiful day though that the
uh freeway empty oh yeah they canceled
school today right my brother was over
my house last night he's a teacher
they canceled that [__]
a lot of people called in that is
beautiful and it's beautiful I think
half the city is not working because
they thought it was going to be like
some catastrophic event but it was
gorgeous Sunny clean one of the best
drives to work I've ever had
to keep the earth clean but you know us
we're like the the post office
hail sleet snow
bombs
gamma rays
gamma-ray bursts oh we'll do the podcast
even from colliding black holes in
distance galaxies
doesn't matter
we're here
um check out Dodger Stadium this was
kind of wild
so you yeah let's let's check it out
here's Dodger Stadium from the air that
this is all a parking lot all the
flooding you see there
that's wild so I have a I have a big
reveal for you
this is an optical illusion oh I'm
seeing right now oh that's just the
that's just the concrete this thing went
crazy viral I was seeing it all over
this just wet concrete yeah
looks like the trees are underwater
it really it got me at first too but uh
I went and checked it out and you'll see
in the dock the Dodgers uh posted a
photo of what it looks like this morning
okay let's dig a Little Closer to the
truth here because the truth is out
there
here's Dodger Stadium this morning
what are they hiding from us why would
Dodger Stadium want to spread this kind
of propaganda what do they have to gain
yo interesting from lying about this
yeah
that's just that's not there's no water
there at all yeah that's pretty dry
all right
wow
kind of symbolic of the whole thing at
least we're here in L.A like you said I
think out in uh Palm Springs they got
they got slammed pretty hard yeah the
the inner desert areas got really [__]
but here is that I mean some people are
really just enjoying the uh
you know having a little extra water in
town
DJ Khaled is going up the LA River on a
jet ski he's sick you remember when um
God did was it Jake Paul or Logan Paul
who was cruising around on a jet ski
after the floods in Houston
remember that I do remember that um
I think it might have been Jake could it
have been both
well the first thing they did I remember
when they went to Puerto Rico is like do
quads down like run over a bunch of
turtles
endangered Turtle Reserves
actually speaking of Logan Paul
just to bring it up
because he's such a piece of [__] he was
getting roasted on social media
for saying uh
apparently he said something about
Oppenheimer being boring because it's
just people talking
and then the bet I saw the best comeback
he's just mad because there weren't
enough dead Japanese people in it oh my
God
oh my God how [__] gnarly is that
that's like the burn of a lifetime I
really hate to say this they didn't show
enough dead Japanese people or something
like that yeah I really hate this area
oh he's saving people say uh rescuing
hurricane victims from their homes dot
dot dot he's so pretty well he made a
video about it yeah yeah I remember we
talked about this
I mean if he did rescue one person then
I guess I can't hit yeah
not really is he just like flooding his
car intentionally yeah go you see where
the spike is at the end the most popular
part oh yeah
[Music]
here
boring
just people driving two hours this video
stopped there's just people driving
laughs
yeah man stop it uh just a continual
reminder that Logan Paul is a scam scam
artist scams people
it's important to know
speaking of which by the way speaking of
baseball stadiums
get a load of this this is what I like
to see
H3 podcast spreading its damn wings dude
soaring to Greater Heights
MLB stadium it's empty
but
it's still playing
that's cool
it'd be nice if there was anybody there
to listen
but I get it this might be what a
typical uh Detroit Tigers game looks
like though okay maybe that's maybe this
is a full yeah they're actually playing
right now capacity
I work as a freelance TV producer and
the scoreboard crew in the stadium
that's awesome
so shout out to helicopter no
90-27 God bless you for that one man
pretty cool there's probably some people
like you know on the bus or something
right outside there heard it maybe a
janitor janitors were working
potentially it all makes a difference
you know
thank you
um oh God this [__] is so insane
Oliver
[__] Oliver of course he's getting me
[__] from alpha morons such an [__]
what the [__] I I I it's almost
inexplicable I mean
this is blowing up once again on Alpha
tick tock
it was posted by an account named
let's see it's got one of these good
names
an account named angry Patriot 2.0
did you check out the uh the rest of the
account I did and you can see just to
give you an idea before I play it where
where they're coming from
um
Epstein conspiracy theorist Tucker
[__] Jesse you're gay that guy yeah
they're posting his dub sneakers
what is it it's like primarily those
three I recognize this guy too I think
this is that psycho like yeah right he's
friends with the fresh that whole crew
okay oh Circa
I'm rude Alex Jones
so I had no idea so the uh the story of
this is really interesting here it is
I'm gonna play it
from somewhere else because we had to
remove the background music
Oliver's dumb annoying song which is
apparently being used by like red pill
owners and frankly Oliver you need to
step in and do something about that
idiot
[__] anyway here it is
of the description's important it is
pretty good it says Oliver trying to
keep it real with feminist YouTuber
Ethan Klein
all right here it is you guys eat your
heart out
doing pretty good it's better than any
of your videos yeah that's for sure
anyway what is the biggest YouTube video
you ever draw was it Vape Nation yeah
back when you were like still kind of
culturally relevant yeah well it was
cool because you used to make stuff and
now you just critique stuff and there's
a big difference between people like me
and people like you yeah what happened
I think everyone that's your fan wants
to know where did it all go wrong I
think people are pretty happy I don't
think so I think a lot of people I mean
if you look at the cultural relevance
and contributions I mean I'm not
contributing and now you're just kind of
here
yeah well well here's where it is it the
money or was it the thing
funny if you just answered the questions
what do you want me to say I want you to
tell me why you stopped making things oh
yeah so okay well first of all let me
remind you this is my [__] show yeah
well it sucks okay so
that this is
my banter with Oliver tree that's a tiny
[__] hat and I know it's like did you
guys not see our outfits I mean these
people are so dumb so let me read the
comments to you guys you know it's very
convenient that they cut out the part
where you beat the [__] out of him
well it's so funny because we're
obviously well here let me let me read
this never thought I'd agree with
something Oliver tree said so much okay
Oliver tree got this man questioning his
content I now like Oliver tree there you
go Oliver you better do something about
this damn I love Oliver tree we all want
to know what happened and yeah it's the
money
idiot
bro I love Oliver tree now
over tree is too real for this homie
pulled the it's my show card
can you believe that
it's so frustrating how dumb they are it
is I mean this is life
but like and then you guys did you guys
not see the tiny hat I'm wearing
like it's not that serious of exchange
now Ethan Klein the new Ethan Klein he
would wear that hat seriously that's
just me yeah that's just who I am now he
loves a little teeny tiny hat that moves
all around his head
this is like the most Fallen fan comment
ever H3 items filthy Frank were Peak
YouTube at one point fell off so bro you
have not grown up
it's time to move on man how long ago
was that like 10 years ago 10 years ago
bro move on to get a job have some kids
or uh maybe it's better if you don't
get a job Oliver was a fan just like
everyone else H3 gave up
uh they're all Fallen fans it really is
true keep my woke there it is
feminist Ethan Club somebody said it
finally someone said something
finally yeah and these all have like
thousands of points
no rules this account gets like no juice
either I stopped being a fan of Ethan
Klein when he just kept complaining
about people [__] what literally what
that's always one [__] day one
[__]
you just don't like the people I
complain about because it hits home
that's literally my like yeah my
number one characteristic if you could
have one word to describe my career my
personality complaining
this one's actually funny I swear to God
I thought Oliver Chi was a character
Ethan made up
maybe it's time to wrap it up Oliver
yeah maybe
yo okay Oliver what's up now to be
honest Oliver tree Isn't So relevant
anymore last time I heard his name it
was him copying a song I don't know what
that accusation is
that sounds about right to me though
I used to [__] with H3 sad face
oh I feel like H3 got a bunch I feel bad
for Trev yeah I'm sorry Trev bro
I'm sorry you haven't ten years ago man
I know
hmm
I feel like H3 just got a bunch of
followers and then got kind of lazy and
stopped putting in real effort
okay
I had a way more followers when I was
doing
my main Channel One
and two we put way more work into
anything I ever used to make I mean come
on
there it is
I thought that was funny I mean the
alpha Tick Tock they can't let it go man
I'm I'm one how did they even like
isolate that clip because this guy
yeah how did angry Patriot media
like how did they Mastermind this uh
it's a good question actually yeah this
is him
I'm realizing is this him in the video
is this him I'd love to see it we do
know that Jeffrey Epstein was doing
tremendous amounts what was the uh
Jeffrey ever seen in Bill Gates were
obsessed with eugenics
I mean kind of yeah
yeah I disavowed them by the way I
disavowed Jeffrey Epstein
and Bill Gates and Bill Gates yeah
yeah can you say that much angry Patriot
2.0 the original one got banned for sure
yeah exactly yeah I don't think that's
him I got some temple in there I don't
know there's another wait let me see
this [__] whether the Earth is
flat or the Earth stop it bro you're
still in my [__] governments have been
making secret bases in Antarctica for a
long time yeah he's a fan he's a fan
huh Mom why don't you have a girlfriend
me on my first date
the Earth is round it doesn't matter
because governments have been making
Secrets
he's doing a bit here interesting wow
huh
not totally sure it's him but it seems
to be there's these two videos with that
guy this bit suffers
yeah let's move on this bit is suffering
it's suffering but I thought you guys
might get a kick out of that I know I
did apparently I saw that on the
subreddit and people were saying there
in the comments that their conservative
family members were sending that to them
to show how badly I got earned
really it's awesome yeah if you can find
the thread on the subreddit
and I mean what morons they're such
making fools of themselves but they
don't care it doesn't matter it doesn't
it doesn't fools it is funny though
Oliver tree my greatest nemesis
um
and now it's like causing us real
problems we should just not we shouldn't
let him it's causing real problems now
yeah
like and like what do I do for him let
him come and promote his dumb [__]
shows that would nobody would be there
if it wasn't for us nobody cares
it's annoying why do I even put up with
them
and now apparently he's a safe haven for
Nazis
so typical
I don't know what that says about him
but I think it means that all of our
trees are Nazi
by proxy you know but we already knew
that
this this is a this is a really fun
thing that's they're doing on the
subreddit
um successful quit
uh they're doing H3 iconic quotes A
through Z and they've actually been
making some good progress here I've been
following along a stands for audio audio
maybe you can play them Zach you think
you could bust these out are they all
sound bites they're all sound bites I
see they're really good too they really
do a good job of picking the best ones I
want to check audio audio audio
so that's a b is for [__] you have
nothing
God that's such a good sound
C is for chestnuts roasting over an open
fire of course
cheers
thank you uh D is of course do you have
your passports did you get your shots
good every time
every time I got it I got it yeah
e is a new entry enough with the
tomatoes
I don't have that one oh I guess we
gotta grab that one
it's actually stop with the tomatoes
stop with that oh wait he must have said
it both ways
he must have said it both ways
uh the next one is F4 you know what it
is
I can just say it
you don't want to play that one I don't
think I have been in here oh you erased
this man you gotta Purge that [__] when
you came back it's not in here
uh G is for I was gay
hey all them together I'm gay
can you hit me with the with the mashup
that's the one that really hits yeah one
second
today I feel uh gay
that's so funny beautiful chorus it
seems like there's some new ones you
have not added to that
to that gay uh Symphony yeah I gotta
update that one uh H is he takes that
five percent of course
he takes that five percent wow
haven't heard that one in a while it's
so good it is a winner I mean it won the
whole damn year and then we had to
retire it yeah oh I I mean this is
fantastic play it play it I'm gonna read
it off at the same time
you want the full one yes starting with
I okay one second I gotta find that one
this is comes from Jordan Peterson's
dream sequence okay go ahead I dreamed I
saw my maternal grandmother sitting by
the bank of a swimming pool and there
was also a river
dimly it had the appearance of a thick
mat of hair the copy pasta she was
stroking herself yeah
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted in fact
paintbrush she pushed it at my face
I raised my arms several this is like to
deflect her hand it's off finally
unwilling to hurt her or interfere with
her any further I let her have her way
she stroked my face with the brush
gently and said like a child isn't it
soft
I looked at her ruined face and said yes
Grandma it is soft whoa I've never heard
that part does he really say that we got
the extended car the Extended Cut has um
Careless Whisper over it
so uh kind of play that one
oh he put He piped in some music well
the from the excerpt we could only find
because it's from his audiobook I
believe bro you would you could not pay
me enough money to tell anyone about
this dream
my I let my grandmother have sex with me
and rub her pubes on my face it was so
soft grandma
so soft
like a paintbrush she parented me with
her pubes
I won't lie I was arrested
I was a wrecked in the dream and also
when I woke up
fully torqued for my grandmother
and her paintbrush
she threw her pubes over her shoulder
like a wet towel
they were long
like a Kung Fu Master's go-to
[Music]
that's wild
so that's it we're caught up
oh and then K is or no there's a few
more actually Jay is just saying Wendy
Williams and mm-hmm K is keemstar shut
up
but I gotta say keemstar shut up the
fact that we have come together as a
show as a community that we have an
iconic sound bite for every letter of
the alphabet it said something
sure does
[Music]
the number one podcast in the world
that's what the [__] I'm saying
oh and finally at the top of the show
here sorry Sora dropped another H3
animation short and she is just
sorry she is just the best I don't know
what to say sorry no that's real
um my audio is coming out real quiet
okay
she's made so many and they're all just
so good sorry yeah
wait it says you're born in New Jersey
that's slander no that's real you were
born in New Jersey no that Israel
[Applause]
what a [__] idiot
what the [__] hold it hold it [__]
you okay just for the record sorry I do
love you but that height difference is
not accurate okay sorry I mean he is
taller but not that much taller he's not
three times my size they just want to
make that clear
and here's another one by her did we
watch this one no
we never watched this one I don't think
so right this was her most recent one
from two months ago yeah
no [__] I I don't remember it well let's
watch it anyway I think it was very good
oh maybe on the Tuesday episode I'm okay
just in case we didn't it's worth
watching sure uh because she's she is
the greatest
um
sorry sorry everybody sorry sorry sorry
I love her uh art style
the attention to details in the
background here it just meant it's
Jordan piercing crying about how how
about poor men who
would be without men what the hell are
we gonna do without men I just I don't
know what to do without him
Society what would Society be
living impossible things
damn it it's okay to be a man and to
build and to make rugs
that's a big swimming pools working
what are we gonna do without men in the
sewers
so
the death
this is a bad fighting for men
oh
so she's so good man she's she really is
such a talent and her her art style is
so unique and good yeah
I'm a huge fan sorry Sora sorry not
beautiful sorry Sora sorry not beautiful
um beautiful all right so today we have
basically uh
a new
Colleen
uh revelation
uh there's been Olivia's left the
building I'm gonna I'm gonna set it up
okay
maybe I should okay here I do I have a I
have a bad habit of setting things up
and then not talking about it so I have
a few more things that goofsa gaffes I'm
gonna cover them and then I'm gonna talk
about the new Colleen stuff also I want
to talk about fresh and fit being kicked
out of YouTube Partner program which is
funny hilarious and awesome and I love
their misery
[__] that [__] they they're permanently
banned from YouTube monetization yes
sorry yes a win for the Matrix
surprising took this long me too
honestly yeah I've been that's the only
surprising thing about it right it took
this long yeah yeah it's funny because
they always cry it's so unfair dude but
it's like dude the fact that they waited
this long to ban you chose
ungodly restraint on their end
you know but that that holds for their
for them and I I love that Bell
oh there's fun Oliver Anthony updates
too the singer
singer but anyway we got all kinds of
stuff so
here by the way you guys remembered my
non-refundable whale watching tour oh
yeah how was it it was great rain or
shine yeah yeah how was it out there I
went out there to the horse and I was
like where the [__] is everyone trainer
shine
but actually captured some footage of me
out there on the ocean during a tropical
storm did you oh exciting
was a little choppy but overall I think
it was fine yeah here we were
I couldn't get a refund so I thought wow
if I'm not gonna get a reason yo
I thought [__] if I can't get a refund
then I'm going out
rain or shine
if I'm dying then they're dying too [__]
it
yeah
new Dan the hater Rock track Yo
wait what that's right you heard it
right look at this guy
um this guy's happy hairy
Arbuckle Arbuckle Happy Harry Arbuckle
and you haven't seen this Dan I have not
so this guy's a tick tock Legend and he
wrote a diddy about you
you sure really happy Harry Happy Harry
Arbuckle my name
is
like a mashed
potatoes
wow
[Applause]
he was singing over uh AC DC yeah I
could tell somehow this is that what he
always does
I think that yeah AC DC yeah Style
parody yeah wow I can't get over how
good those background music removers are
I mean yeah it's pretty good it sounds
like the man just recorded that I'm
Daniela [__] technology is awesome
bring the AI
Pizza yeah
hairy happy wait let me look up his
account so it wasn't him singing or wait
no it is him okay it is like happy Harry
Arbuckle
let me see what else this guy gets up to
um Harry
Arbuckle yeah he's bit he's a big deal
out here on Tick Tock actually
damn oh congratulations Dan this one did
fighting quite well for him exciting let
me see Steam here Olivia no I'm so sorry
no every year I watched the Glastonbury
Festival on TV and after the Sunday
there's like there's music
I'm trying to find another flourish of
his
um it's gonna have Pottery music though
he has thoughts on the Oasis reunion oh
me too hard about the question of
whether Oasis should reform it's been
ages since I've been together and you
know they fell out constantly when they
were together over the years the public
have swayed between lacking null and
then lacking Liam and currently
everybody will actually
very good oh this is that's that's some
good juice dude that's way better than
any Colleen drama well here is this
drama well hold on here he talks about
his we need an oasis PowerPoint no no no
the Gallagher brothers Saga yeah give me
five years
guys I found something better he does an
arthritis update so soon as I've been to
see the Arctic Monkeys this week I
thought I'd revisit this hit stop making
the ass at me I'll stop making any eyes
at you what it is that surprises me is
that I don't think you really do because
your shoulders are frozen it's arthritis
yeah you're an explosion it's diarrhea
your name isn't real but don't give a
sound a lot of fears
he's Italian
that's Happy
Harry can I make a Content suggestion to
you
the one you did about Dan got 650 000
views I think we need more H3 related
yeah damns yeah
you know
just putting it out there
elon's new social app
Elon Instagram okay I'll give it down
then that's a pretty good
all right
okay
all right they love it the people they
love people love it
oh yeah this is what I wanted to show
you guys uh before we get into to
Colleen's stuff this is the last one
here
um Logan Paul getting roasted on Twitter
I have the link here
I'm going to see Oppenheimer tonight
actually
Arya uh-huh finally gonna see it
interesting interesting you think you'll
walk out
I don't think I mean I'm cool with
people there's a lot of talking when I
go to this I'm expecting people to talk
right in a movie it's a visual medium
it's the point
uh he's dis oh this is what I told you
he's disappointed there weren't actually
any dead Japanese people oh my God shout
out to this guy
God how do you even come back from that
Logan I really need to say this
go ahead I think there's someone hanging
right there
come on man
we're all trying to move on from that
bro come on man when you keep saying it
didn't you guys see uh uh Oppenheimer
yep did you love it uh it was fine it
was okay I think it was very Oscar baby
I gave my review on Friday that I
thought we talked about it yeah my
complaint was that uh all the physicists
they cast too many [__] long dicks
studs out there right it really removed
me believing that these guys were
yes like physicists you know I have a
kind of a rule about movies whenever I
see someone cast a movie like that it's
almost always terrible
when they're like starring all these
[__] people for no reason all these
Mega celebrities don't look up that
Netflix movie during quarantine that was
like
star Ariana Grande was in it right worst
movie ever don't look up yeah they're
never good yeah although I'll be honest
I didn't hate that movie I'll be honest
I liked it too I thought it was me it
was pretty pretty DiCaprio
like look at this the guy on the right
is supposed to be Matt Damon
that ain't no Matt Damon
let me see oh come on I could have
played this guy you should have played
this guy
that's it this one okay at least like
I'll say uh or what's his name this main
character Killeen Murphy like he
actually looked pretty much the part I
like that casting dead ringer to be
honest with you like even from the back
shots there's this it looked just like
him I'm a fan of his I love how is this
not Chris Christie
he's tucked in there he's got his fupa
on display Don't Call Him a fat pig you
can't do it I wouldn't
the [__] but yeah I agree I don't like
it you know what I mean
coming a Manhattan Project to uh design
that belt buckle right there hold on now
here's who we really needed he's a
bureaucrat who's got the same body type
and
you know I think he has what it takes
Chris Christie gorgeous tucked in and
ready to go my friends
that's a brave man
[Applause]
wow I gotta tell you something this man
has bravery like I could never happen my
whole life
this man walked out in front of 50 000
people
it's a hundred and four of them with his
dick straight up gift wrapped
and it's not flattering either let me
tell you that Mr Christie talking your
dick between your legs
yep
but we love that for you and you're a
brave man and we love that we love
Bravery here on the podcast
all right Olivia
so at the moment
um a Creator named
uh swoop
made a four hour
uh investigation
into
what I understand the main thrust of was
into one of Colleen's detractors
specifically Johnny was that the main
thrust of the video of this new video
yes it was happy birthday swoop did
as well swoop has been doing a Colleen
docu-series and a part of that was that
she did interviews with a lot of the
victims and in her quest to gather all
this evidence and all these stories she
noticed inconsistencies and like weird
things occurring with one specific
victim who we did speak to on the show
right and I'm here to present
what it is she found and I'd really
encourage everybody it's four hours but
I really encourage the watch she worked
so hard her team worked so hard yes
again I do want to emphasize we'll put
the link in the description because I
think we're gonna be doing our best to
kind of summarize but it is a four hour
long video so appreciate their work and
you know
if you have nothing going on in your
life
feel free to watch this no offense if
you've got everything no offense well no
yeah we love that for you here we go
it's only a little longer than an
industry podcast literally
okay
why'd you have to say that like that
this is true
um sometimes we do go over four hours as
a matter of fact
damn it damn why you [__] yourself
so let's put it in the uh description
let's put it in chat just to send her
love all right yeah I'm adding it right
now so with all that being said
all right and a big thank you to swoop
now the reason I think it's important to
talk about this is because
if this this mainly regards her
ex-husband Josh yeah Joshua Evans who
somebody came on the show and made
accusations against this man that he's a
groomer and so if there is evidence that
counters that I do feel that it's our
responsibility to
uh to show that event 100 you know what
I mean because because listen those are
those are heavy heavy accusations to say
against somebody yeah huge it's like
such a large audience as well so I I
feel obligated to at least uh show the
other side right I agree
so if you want to get started I'm ready
and also we're trying to reach out to
Josh we're hopefully yes we we made
contact publicly on Twitter
um he saw my DM he said he'll get back
to me so hopefully he's willing to call
okay Josh if you're out there we are
sending the signal yeah please with
peace and love okay so go ahead uh
Olivia
we go swoop titled her video the devil
and Colleen Ballinger's Shadow now can I
just
I want to put out a disclaimer here
because
I know that this is all about Johnny
bending the truth fabricating stuff
whatever I just want to temper our
our language a little bit about Johnny
yeah I want to encourage people to not
I mean this guy at the end of the day is
a private person or well he came out
publicly but he's just a dude
and so no matter what he's done and I
don't know yet
how outraged I'll be
or not I want people to know do not mess
with this guy okay let's let's temper
our language about him because and the
reason I say that specifically is
because he is just a normal dude he's
not a YouTuber he doesn't have a
platform he's not he doesn't have a
platform exactly so you know got to be
careful with this kind of stuff yeah I
mean he's still a person after all and
so well with that being said
uh let's can let's go ahead and Venture
forth
the devil and Colleen Ballinger's Shadow
yes that's a pretty wow yeah heavy duty
title agree
so if we would like to move on this is
Swoop Spanky Valentine We Stand swoop
what's her name uh Spanky Valentine is
that a real name I don't know but I know
that that's her Instagram so the swoop
is her channel name yes and her
stage name and her name's name is Spanky
Spanky
um swoop is a documentarian on YouTube
whose ethos is um it's not drama it's
dangerous so she covers
serious topics um she's very candid
about the fact that she is a survivor of
uh domestic abuse and sexual grooming so
she works very closely and intensely
with her subjects and those she's
interviewing and she really really you
can tell how much she cares about all of
it and she has a team who helps her to
put together her research and everything
um she has 600 000 Subs so she's a
pretty you know good sized Channel but
this video is four hours and a lot of
people are watching him and 1.5 million
after four days that's that's really
good
that is significant I just curious what
kind of other videos she's putting out
went to the worst nail salon
Glam and Gore I didn't follow that one
this is already her fourth oh no this is
one from one month ago also a quick
correction about Johnny he does have a
YouTube channel where he's been making a
lot about this situation right now he it
he doesn't have a huge platform but to
correct the record he does have okay oh
he has AK Subs okay
he's not like he doesn't do this for a
living he's not I think he's trying to
he's trying to yeah okay that might
explain some things then yeah all right
so we stand swoop we she swooped in and
stolen our hearts one hundo P that's why
we call her Spanky Valentine she have
Amber eyes
I'll bet you she does wow those are
beautiful Hazels actually we love those
I meant to say hazel Hazel get up no
Amber take it back it's close enough
right let's be real Amber is not as good
as hazeln it's just not well thank you
for saying so as a hazel-eyed man I wish
I was Hazel like you but I'm Amber [__]
[__] I have shitty Amber eyes
all right
all right quick reminder who is Johnny
Silvestri he is a 27 year old young man
we had him on the show he was a Colleen
Josh Super Fan he met them when he was
15. he would tiny chat with them he
would video chat with them um he told us
the story of when Josh gave him his
phone number he wrote it down on a paper
crown we found out in this interview
with swoop that actually Johnny's
parents were there when Josh gave him
the crown and um they were proud of him
for getting that and securing like a
possible job so that was just one thing
that was found I remember Johnny he was
the guy that went on touring with them
and he was very talkative during the
interview he had a lot to say
yes and um
he had beef with her best friend yes he
accused Corey DeSoto of verbally and
emotionally abused and then he accused
Josh her acts of grooming him yes that
was the most serious allegation of them
all is that he accused Joshua Evans of
grooming him and he even used the words
in one of his tweets you'll see later he
called him baby even worse than Colleen
wow which is very serious it almost
implies something worse it happened that
we don't know about right
because
how is that possible right right
okay
[__] me right
so who is Johnny
he's on stage I just included some more
photos that's them performing on her bus
tour that's one of the tweets where he
accuses Josh of grooming him this is
from June 7th of this year that was the
first time he made an allegation that
Joshua Evans groomed him it was in June
this year so I'll read it he said I was
groomed by Josh as a teen and then they
literally ended up doing almost the
exact same [__] he did to me
they're no different and there's so much
more behind all of this so over a decade
of manipulation and torment for multiple
sources and that's just my story
yeah so that's the first one that he had
put out so this six hour long phone call
this is the interview that swoop held
with Johnny so after their interview
Johnny went public and was like swoop
and I just did a six hour interview wow
wow and apparently he was like parading
this around and like talking about how
important his story was because of the
six hours like Adam had talked about how
uh actually I I included that link later
so he didn't realize he was being like
deposed
um no because it sounds like that's what
was happening there are many there are
many clips that I include later well
you'll see that swoop is obviously
trying to figure out what's going on and
I think that he just had Noah he was
just like giving and giving and giving
because it seems like she was probing
him for inconsistencies and
yeah well she said that she just talked
in circles for she said that it was six
hours because he would say something and
then they would return to it later and
he would say something completely
different really yeah so she said that
she would pick up on inconsistencies so
if you go to the next slide it sounds
like this interview was in fact a
disaster for him it does sound that way
yeah here we go
um so here's one of the inconsistencies
um in the first link
um in that was an interview that swoop
held with Johnny via Twitter
um there is audio of Johnny saying that
he was in fact groomed by Trent
Ballinger because we were talking about
it and he never mentioned that right
which if he was he doesn't need to be
forthcoming about it totally although
he's well here so I'll watch this link
let's see
this is Swoop Trent Ballinger the reason
I've personally known that Trent
Ballinger has been an issue for so long
is because I was groomed by him and
honestly it took Oliver's Story to kind
of wake me up from that situation as
well this was further backed up by a
tweet Johnny made on June 17th when he
explicitly calls himself a victim of
trents now here's him discussing Trent
Ballinger wow okay interesting so he
just okay so that information just came
out
in this phone call they had yes all of
this information uh that swoop was able
to piece together came out in this talk
that came out a couple days ago so when
did this interview take place because
this tweet's from June 17th July so this
is like July 2nd
because she called to clarify with him
the date was
my point is this tweet is from before
the phone call
he said I want to point out that even
last week I still was trying to defend
these people and I didn't realize I'm
glad Oliver came out with this story
honestly it helped me realize I was a
victim of trents as well
and I was still being persuaded to
believe in his innocence
interesting right should I keep watching
or is this it um no you should click on
the other link okay and then we'll go
ahead to this one and then this was
during their six hour interview
with Trent I feel like our conversations
were inappropriate in the sense that he
was talking to an underage child but I
don't personally feel like Trent really
crossed any boundaries with me and
followed that by saying this with Trent
I had a weird dynamic with Corey
I didn't like him I'm not sure if he
liked me but I wouldn't consider myself
as a groomed victim by either of those
people so in one interview he accuses
Trent of being his groomer in
yeah that's pretty that's pretty heavy I
mean because yes
just come out on our platform and said
explicitly that he groomed me so
that level of inconsistency is a little
concerning just because
you really need to be careful with an
accusation like that yeah to just you
know
just back walk it back just you know
subtly right it's dangerous oh yeah
Barry especially
when they're store like people who whose
stories
are
Oliver's yeah that's what I'm that's
what I'm gnarly it's like let
I don't know Oliver's Story is just as
important you know what I mean
uh yeah definitely of course
so uh should I keep watching that link
or we're good no okay
interesting um so he also after those
quotes about Trent he also like posted
screenshots that Trent had reached out
to him post uh like people coming out
and he was like don't worry Trent like I
remember the good times and like that's
it was an interesting text to see is
that next
no that was just that's an off he
tweeted that out when I tweeted a
picture of a message they had yeah they
were both of age I can pull it up for
you if you want it yeah because Trent is
like the straight up
this man is is in my opinion a straight
up pedophile Trent
so like any any information we have
about him is good
based on his interaction with Oliver
um
this guy is probably in my opinion a
public menace
and probably in my opinion
talking to other kids in a similar
fashion
and probably in my opinion
I'll just hit the button
[Music]
and let them use their imagination
but I can't line it up like that
it's just a fact in my opinion all right
so uh are you looking for it yeah I'm
looking for it okay and we could skip it
it's fine or have uh someone else look
for it okay yeah charge for it it's uh
the the Tweet says like Trent Ballinger
is the only Bounder to reach out to me
since the accusations if that helps okay
so now we're moving on to Adam yes
inconsistencies involving Adam in the
six hour phone call
um swoop alleges in her dock that Johnny
told stories
about himself when in actuality swoop
knew that those things had happened to
Adam and so um that was concerning to
her
um she also said that Johnny would get
timelines so wrong to where she had to
really go back and question it um like
he would say that Adam was a part of the
tiny chat group but Adam would have been
10 years old when that was happening and
so Adam says in this talk that is not
true I was not in tiny chats I was not
old enough yet I like wasn't in the
fandom yet at that age tiny chats is
that just like an old thing that was the
video chats that he was telling us about
it's like Skype okay okay okay yeah
so and then at one point in the phone
call he said that he did bully Adam on
the tiny chats in another he said that
he he didn't participate in the bullying
of Adam and Adam is like I wasn't
bullied because I wasn't in tiny chats
so that was just an inconsistency that
she picked up on
I see okay
so we have no links here no the Trisha
one is this is the guy who's put out
yeah although so this part's weird
because
he's the one that was like yeah um
Colleen used to make fun of Trisha's
body
to me
and then he showed receipts but the
thing that is confusing
is that Colleen basically best up to it
right so
but okay there's inconsistencies let's
see what they are well so Johnny was of
age when he was sending uh nudes of
Trisha back and forth uh we knew that
already
um in the first clip uh Johnny revealed
talking uh that he would participate in
the unsolicited sending of Tricia's
nudes so instead of what he was saying
which was that Colleen was just out of
the blue send Tricia's nudes he said to
swoop like I would look up on Google
Trisha Paytas nudes and I would send
them I mean that doesn't surprise me
right but he's just a kid he did not um
if you go to the third clip then uh he
told Adam that Adam when he came out
with the fact that Colleen had sent
Trisha's nudes to Adam Johnny was like
you need to clarify Adam that you
participated
um in the bullying and that it was
inappropriate what yeah
all right let me watch these in order I
want to see all the clips you pulled
okay
if I'd find a photo I'd follow Trisha so
if she'd post something publicly or
sometimes I would literally just go to
Google and type in like Trisha pay this
nude but I never did it to body shame
Trish I will say on one account there
was something that was nasty of me that
I said in regards to her body yeah
Johnny
in my opinion
I assume this is what they were doing
they were being catty but he's a nobody
this is Colleen's Tricia's friend you
know he's just trying to [__] be cool
with his uh so once Johnny put the
screenshots up of one Colleen would send
Trish's nudes yeah um in a pretty
not helpful way he it didn't really
cover much the Emojis used were like
meant to be funny
um so in the second clip you'll see the
real reason why Johnny took the
screenshots down if you remember on our
podcast you asked and he said I think
that they served their purpose so I took
them down oh interesting feel great that
I used Trish at her expense but I guess
what does help me sleep at night is
knowing that I wasn't friends with Trish
she was just this Untouchable public
figure to me does that make it okay
after hearing this I wanted to ask
Johnny something important I I'm curious
to know at what point did you have the
realization that the the sending of
Trisha nudes was inappropriate there was
I mean I mean again it's I know he's
like he's like how old is he at the time
yeah over 20. he's over 20. yeah uh
first of all I know it's [__] up but I
do want to emphasize when he's talking
to his Idol and she's sending him yes
like it's just there's some parents that
he would participate he would
reciprocate yeah but keep watching that
clip keep watching I mean something
always felt wrong morally deep down but
I think I was just more excited over the
fact that it was a way to created a bond
between me and these people listen I'm
not gonna get into body language [__] we
will leave that to observe in the
behavioral panel but I do find it so
uncomfortable that Johnny is grinning
ear to ear while he's saying this and he
continues well when did when do you
think that you maybe it was in the oh no
he's got the spittle collection
when you talk too much I had a math
teacher
I'm so paranoid about this happening if
I if I know I'm well I sit here and talk
all the time you ever seen a spittle you
know what it's going to be on your [__]
no oh really no not really huh I was
saying I haven't seen it okay but just
be emphatic don't say not really well
armies open doubt I know there's going
to be a post on the subreddit now no
because you brought it up of some
episode from like three years ago that
[__] tonsil Stone on your lip
if you see a white dot on my lips it's
discoloration it's not spittle
guarantee you because I'm on my [__] I
had a math teacher he would get the
gnarliest spittle he was such a nice guy
too but he would talk and he would he
was foaming and it was like it just
looked like sludge on both sides of his
mouth man have you ever seen someone get
the little dot in the middle of their
lip and then it there's like a string
every time they open their mouth yeah he
had that too it's so dry it's like drink
some water man oh my God that's all you
gotta do hydrate a little bit my brother
oh Johnny
of all the things you've done this is
the one I find most offensive
not the spittle
the last couple of years uh did you have
a moment where you were like you know
that's it that's the only thing that's
there locked in all you hear is
it gonna do try hearing anything any
tricks
came back at the the the nude photos
thing and you thought Ah that's actually
really wrong watching Trisha's video the
difference between her and Colleen's
videos were Colleen made an ass out of
herself and thought she was being cute
and funny and gonna have a little bit
still relevant yeah moment to call Trish
what you want but like I felt the
authenticity and I felt the hurt
and yeah Trisha she came off devastated
well now that now that Trisha has made a
video Patricia is a victim in this story
oh
the the text on screen is a note from
swoop says it took me over 20 minutes to
try and get him to consider taking
Tricia's picks down right which is good
I mean listen if you feel bad about it
right little spittle's still there
right it's still there dude 20 minutes
later man well at least it's not bigger
20 minutes talking it's true the
consistency is there I wanted to ask if
there might be a time where you might
consider taking those tweets down now
that they kind of have served their
purpose some of them did get taken down
but that is actually why I was put in
Twitter jail
um because of some of the [__] is
Twitter Jill he was locked out of his
Twitter account she said I do not
believe this adult man is at all sorry
for exploiting Trisha I mean
okay I mean listen that's that's an
opinion I don't I don't know right so
you don't have to keep watching if you
want it was just to show that but again
I'm not my blaming in this situation is
really not falling on him that's my
opinion okay
you know
and I think he could have censored them
what was I didn't don't remember was it
it was like a tiny little flower over
her like you could see you could see
what was going on it was it was invasive
and it was weird
to to show that Colleen did send these
photos so you think he should have I
think he should have censored them a
little bit better censored them better
at least oh God why'd you do this
Cameron
it's just the strong image that came to
mind
why would you do that
oh no reason double mode activated it's
a spittle [__] Rapids exactly spittle
or vampiric I mean what the hell I
Googled rabies dog
I got a good chance of surviving I think
rabies yeah that'll be fine yeah yeah
yeah I did not [__] my dog
um okay so we're done with this clip
yeah so he should have uh
was he getting [__] for not censoring it
because I mean she I think people felt
weird about it but I mean people were
more
occupied with the fact that like this
proved it happened yeah because it is
good that he shared that right
ultimately because it was an important
piece of evidence in the Colleen thing
so the criticism is that I can see him
I can see him
not censoring it enough
but maybe he could have erased it and
censored it and repoed it up or or I see
that he just erased it I I don't know he
left one up
he left one up yeah
for himself
okay
um and then if you want to watch the
third clip that's where Adam explains
that Johnny told him he had to
just like make a distinction between the
fact that he it was involved in the
bullying but Johnny was not hmm like
angry that this is the second time on
this call with you today that I'm saying
a similar thing where he has told us
both two different stories he told me oh
well what you did was really bad but
Colleen used to just send them to me and
make me really uncomfortable he told you
that you were did something bad in that
situation he told me that I was the one
being inappropriate whereas Colleen was
harassing him with them because of me
because me and Colleen and I had said
this on the record it was our in-between
bet back and forth right I was 14 she
was whatever 30 something was 14 30
something and Johnny said to me that
basically I was acting inappropriate and
she was being harassed by Colleen
Colleen sending them to him and our
stories were different so if I was gonna
go on the record with it I had to make
that distinction
angry knowing that not only again with
the other one but this time that you
were told a different story than what I
was
legitimately
um
that the controversy was that he came on
the next day
and acted like he's the one that chose
them to delete them out of the kindness
of the good heart right
right so he just he's being he's being
the misleading there sure and he also
did use um
swords on our on the Pod she said do you
think they've served their purpose and
then it's a little sneaky because he's
basically
yeah this hadn't come out and it wasn't
going to come out for a while so he's
sneakily kind of it's like ooh that's a
good angle yeah so next um now what
happened here I didn't understand oh
okay so basically it was just that like
swoop was told one story which was that
he would get the photos of Trisha online
as well and send them and then he told
Adam that he would not do that and that
because Adam would do that when he was a
minor though but Johnny was not a minor
but because Adam would do that he had to
say that in his videos when he talked
about it about the fact that Colleen
would send them to him
so they were both trading Trisha nudes
with Colleen yeah separately yep
and then it's just her thing he was was
saying Adam you are [__] up for
sending these to her I don't know if he
was that or just a paraphrase yes he was
saying Adam you're you're [__] up for
sending them back to him I didn't do
that so you have to tell people that you
did that
oh even though you were a minor and I
wasn't
okay
I'm gonna watch this again okay it's
this is four hours I'm trying to
condense yes you know what I mean take
your time I want to make sure that
okay like I agree that this is the
second time on this call with you today
that I'm saying a similar thing where he
has told us both two different stories
he told me oh well what you did was
really bad but Colleen used to just send
them to me and make me really
uncomfortable he told you that you
did something bad in that situation he
told me that I was the one being
inappropriate whereas Colleen was
harassing him with them because of me
because me and Colleen and I had said
this on the record it was our in-between
bet back and forth right I was 14 she
was whatever 30 something it was 14 30
something and Johnny said to me that
basically I was acting inappropriate and
he was being harassed by Colleen Colleen
sending them to him and our stories were
different so if I was gonna go on the
record with it I had to make that
distinction so that's that's crazy
Ray okay I understand
so when did this conversation between
him and Adam happened chronologically
um in between
the allegations and
the interview so end of June early July
okay so this is a recent combo yeah so
Johnny went to Adam
and he says we've both been exchanging
nudes of Trisha with Colleen
the difference is I never sent it right
and I felt like Colleen was sending it
to me and harassing me
so you need to you need to admit that
you're worse than me because you were
reciprocating yes as a child yes
and so he comes out looking better
even though on paper
Adam's a child
and John is in his 20s
do I have that right yeah
this one's a this one is a people are
saying I don't have the context I don't
know I mean listen I separated
everything in a way that I think it will
make sense at the end okay guys just
we're gonna we're gonna figure this out
we're gonna figure it out you guys and I
see lots of I'm too high for this
I'm trying to untangle it first for you
guys as much as possible all right so
we've seen enough of this one yeah okay
so
um Ben swoop touches on Johnny's
delusions of grandeur in the first clip
Adam expresses to swoop and tells her a
story about when Johnny told him that
his story was more important than Adams
okay delusions of grandeur hmm
and he was talking to me about how
emotional this was going to be for him
to make and I was like well of course
I'm going to support you I specifically
remember telling him like I'll watch it
on my twitch and I'll re-upload it to
YouTube and I'll redirect everyone your
way like everyone needs to hear you like
yours is equally as important as mine
and I remember his response to that was
or even more important was exactly the
words he said and it will always stand
out to me I ended up doing that with
that video
but he mentioned that he always wanted
to speak about Josh and the reason I
didn't say anything was because me and
Josh had talked privately before and we
talked about things and it wasn't my
situation so I didn't really say
anything but his overall aim was to make
this to build an audience and then make
the Josh video and he had made that very
clear
okay
so I got it
hey
his story is more important than Adams
what did you get to the party said maybe
even more important yeah yeah okay even
more important which is obviously pretty
nutty to say
and then I mean the ultimate crime here
is the Josh stuff which is right which
is leading that's the end of it yeah I
put that all together so then the second
clip on this is um
is Johnny not everyone understands
he's pretty much saying that if it were
sexual grooming it would have been
better but because it wasn't it's worse
click it it's okay
it's really different Let's Twist our
minds around that that's that grooming
doesn't always have a school component
to it or a whole kind of end goal so
that it can have different attempts at
what it's leading towards what do you
think that Josh was grooming you for the
most disturbing part
you would think it would be super
disturbing if it was well but that would
just be pretty cut and dry but never
once did I ever feel like these people
wanted to come on to me sadly or any
intent to exploit me in any ways no yeah
so oh maybe this is a good time to
address another issue I face with Johnny
Silvestri he used my own quote about how
not all grooming is set to make the
point that to him his non-sex grooming
is worse Johnny was made very aware on
multiple occasions that as a child I was
groomed and repeatedly separately abused
for years the most disturbing part you
would think it would be super disturbing
if it was sexual but that would just be
pretty cut and dry people don't quite
understand what grooming is which is why
I appreciated your breakdown of it in
the first segment I actually highlighted
that and posted it on Tick Tock it could
solely be for power which to me
sounds so much more disturbing I mean
sexually is horrific but just
for no motive other than power and
boredom that is almost more disturbing
than having a very set in stone motive
behind what you're doing because I
cannot confidently say what Joshua's
motive was even that's pretty wild he he
has a tendency to just prioritize his
own story yeah his own experiences above
yeah and really in you know in the
concept like yeah I know you were like
you were groomed for uh to be a essayed
but I was groomed for no reason and
that's way worse right it's like he has
a monopoly on being the victim it's like
it's very it's very competitive
very interesting
trying to profile him right
I do get the sense he's kind of just
talking at this point yes he's kind of
just
driving through the Mist
can't see much in front of him you know
what I mean like just talking like an
Oppenheimer right it's just like the up
and running right I've said it once and
I listen I know what it is because I've
done it and this is the Michael Scott
thing you just start a sentence and then
figure it out yeah I get the sense
that's Johnny uh something Johnny's
partaking in but obviously yeah I can
see that that that's a crazy thing to
say that's pretty pretty offensive other
offensive comments that he made on this
call if you go to the next slide
um his comments on domestic violence
were or domestic abuse were
not very sensitive Johnny is very aware
now that Joshua has said he was
domestically a in his relationship with
Colleen yet Johnny felt it important to
drag him in our interview for not
proposing to Colleen his alleged abuser
soon enough you were a grown man in an
abusive relationship and you stayed in
it and follows It Up Wait hold on hold
on so Johnny's on this Warpath against
her ex Josh
this is what he said my life was toxic
me me me me you are grown man in an
abusive relationship and you stayed in
it wait
you both abused each other wait
that's crazy yeah like we're we're all
as a society moved past these kinds of
silly arguments about abuse I agree like
oh you stayed so it's your fault like we
know you can't say that to a woman
to me that nobody
was Did anyone say anything about this
at the time
I'll be honest I don't remember
I did not see this
he says I know these stories you didn't
care about my life and my pain when you
completely disrespect disregarded me how
about some Humanity for me Joshua I do
remember seeing some things that I was
just like
but a lot of people I think were very
they were trying to be really delicate
and like not question because obviously
like you don't that's not really your
first your first go-to we have no reason
to think he was lying about everything
exactly I wouldn't and I would never uh
I would never say that yeah without any
you know any reason sheesh that's [__]
up right but yeah this is a this is a
wild tick yeah and if you keep watching
he seems something crazy he seems
frankly like he just has a vendetta
against Josh and I I wonder why yeah
let's keep I think okay we'll see I have
more so next yeah
oh wait if you want to keep watching
that clip he does say something crazy
okay yep
knit Johnny is very aware now that
Joshua has said he was domestically a in
his relationship with Colleen yet Johnny
felt it important to drag him in our
interview for not proposing to Colleen
his alleged abuser soon enough you were
a grown man in an abusive relationship
and you stayed in it and follows it up
to my face by saying this he actively
chose to remain in this relationship bro
you can't
that's like such a crazy take I know
that's really weird that he would even
like think that you could say that is it
because he's a guy I don't know
I feel like you would know you can't say
that to a woman
he had so many outs he didn't propose
for like nine years what bro what
this is crazy logic brother
oh geez why did you enter a marriage
that was so toxic if you knew it was so
bad you must have wanted something out
of it and it bit you in the ass he yeah
like probably a partner
Club family
and he's saying all of this to swoop who
has been so candid with him about her
experiences she that's yeah she seems to
be very you know
aware of of how you know
people say [__] like this to downplay
others experiences yeah there's one more
line I mean this this take is like so
archaic it's almost it's like the what
you would see from like fresh and fit
right when talking about a woman yeah
it's shocking yes it's bad
he [__] around and found out and what
bro
I don't you did not just say that that's
not even the line I wanted you to hear
bro you did not just say that he [__]
around and found out and got abuse
you [__] around and found out
that's what you get
yes he [__] around and found out and
now he's just
upset about it
dude what
no spittle okay that's good so so okay
that I mean obviously what he's saying
is horrific but at least no spill no
spittle he's clean
ah Johnny not only shamed Joshua for not
proposing to Colleen soon enough but he
also shamed him for not leaving soon
enough stating that an alleged domestic
Survivor quote [__] around and found
out and he's said that for the entire
world to see for anyone like you out
there who has survived abuse and I know
that you're out there and I am so sorry
you have to hear disgusting words like
his and he said that to my face knowing
that I'm a Survivor of DB so sorry
fellow survivors but according to
Jonathan Silvestri I guess we all [__]
around and found out at this
yeah that's that's that's like
I didn't even think fresh and fit would
say something like that no but like I
would yeah like oh yeah I beat her uh
why did she marry him she [__] and she
got her she would I hear it yeah like
imagine this she's probably said exactly
that and imagine this let's let's flip
the script and then pretend freshen fits
at it yeah yeah
let's say a football player's girlfriend
he beats he beats her up
and then they're like listen
she decided to marry him she [__]
around and found out
I think it wouldn't surprise me but it
would be shocking enough to where we'd
talk about it you know
it'd be like I can't [__] believe
that they said this but
they're fresh and fit they suck yeah
we're still questioning if fresh and fit
would say that I think they definitely
would they would they're like she
deserved it yeah they'd probably be I
feel like we've watched that they would
probably be like listen I don't know
what she did but she definitely deserved
to get her ass
which is frankly like just a little less
slick way of saying what he said kind of
right you [__] around and found out
wow
I'm trying I'm just trying to put myself
in his mind where he thought that this
was the right thing to say it's I think
it's the he has a lot of hatred he hates
Josh
he wants bad things to happen to Josh
yeah
do we know why
or do we have to say we we'll talk about
it okay
wow he really hates Josh and he's I it's
I get the sense that he's willing to
basically say or do anything to hurt
Josh because his whole campaign was
against Josh yes basically yeah
some people actually do have the theory
that like he was there taking heat off
of Colleen because he didn't have any
serious allegations against her besides
like some weird things she would say on
tour and the fact that like he she
didn't stand up for him with Corey so
some that is I don't really think that I
think that that's something
yeah but that is something that's living
on the Colleen snark credit I mean I
would say I would see it the other way
where it's like Colleen is already
buried so now let's focus people on Josh
I wouldn't see it as like I'm trying to
get heat off Pauline because that's
that's just not what happened
that's why I don't care that he was a
victim bro I know the [__] he says right
now is crazy right now it's crazy I
guess he I guess his his point of view
is that he victimized me therefore he
deserved it that's next level
yo your next level bro
okay I guess we all [__] around and
found out at this point I don't care
that he was a victim because we're not
talking about that story anymore if he
wanted to talk about that story he had
every opportunity in 2016.
okay wait okay let me unpack that
Josh was 16. what happened to Josh when
he was 16. in 2015
Joshua and Colleen got a divorce okay so
he's saying if you were abused by your
ex-wife you could have talked about it
then what did he mean about 16 2016. oh
2016. again like another classic uh
Survivor attack line right which is like
if
the proof that you're lying about this
is the fact that you waited this long
to talk about it he's hitting like every
Survivor fallacy there is it's also
interesting because a lot of the stuff
that he's alleging and talking about
took place years ago also
you're right so
why didn't you talk about the Trisha
thing so what what do you stand for I I
I'm having a hard time
um
these are bad these are bad opinions
right these are bad
I just don't understand how we could how
we can miss the point so hard because
he's like so involved in what everyone's
saying what everyone's talking about the
man knows the right way to handle
someone who's making an accusation but
like still somehow he's saying all the
wrong things
Johnny
my boy yeah
what's the story with Johnny Appleseed
is he a real was he a real guy apple
seed I think he was a real guy yeah uh I
think there was a real Johnny Appleseed
I don't think I don't think he's like a
Paul Bunyan situation you know but there
was a dude who spread his [__] apple
seeds
statue of him here
I always love Johnny Appleseed I thought
that was such a cool do you think that
Johnny apples there's probably some dark
underbelly to the Johnny Appleseed yeah
he was already he was you know what I
mean that's for sure like
like all of those kind of should I blend
that what should I button that joke oh I
didn't even hear what you said I said he
was [__] kids
I mean
he's nice I mean we don't know he may
have the Johnny Appleseed I was feeling
in context of the conversation maybe it
was oh okay I mean I think I think it's
too late
Johnny Appleseed's real name was John
Chapman he was born and uh Leominster
Massachusetts
1774. his dream was to produce so many
apples that no one would ever go hungry
okay this guy's a saint that sounds
lovely although Legend paints a picture
of Johnny as a dreamy Wanderer planting
apple seeds throughout the countryside
researchers revealed him to be a careful
organized businessman who over a period
of 50 years bought and sold tracks of
land and developed thousands of
productive apple trees
did he sell the seat did he sell the
apples though is he just a shrewd Apple
salesman it sounds like this is you know
this is Corporate propaganda in a way
selling apples yeah
that's like calling Bill Gates Billy uh
window seed
he just wanted everybody to have windows
Yep for the good of the nation
well anyway I was gonna my point of this
whole tangent is that um
Johnny here is like Johnny Appleseed
except he instead of seeds he drops uh
terrible takes
um swoop just became a member
hi girl hi girl I hope we're doing you
proud
yeah every I mean like people are saying
I'm not having the full contacts and I
understand right we'll get there so
that's what we're here to do I we're
untangling
try and make it make more sense when I
was telling it in a shorter form I'm get
I'm understanding thank you but again I
just want to encourage people to go
watch her whole vid 100 I I also
encourage
isn't there a Johnny Appleseed song
I'm sure there is uh that's not a badass
I don't know though I don't know one
hmm
my seed is all over this place Johnny
feed be like
[Laughter]
all right back to to swoop
okay I'm not even gonna waste my breath
explaining how absolutely disgusting
that was the line I was showing you to
hear the he could have talked about it
in 2016.
dude that's nuts I mean that's basically
been like no Nazis are not that bad
right like it's that level of
unself-awareness
it's pure ignorance it's it's very
confusing like yeah I mean the Nazis did
some stuff but they build roads and
stuff
laughs like the [__] I'm not saying he's
a Nazi for the record
well it wouldn't be surprised I'm
kidding I'm kidding all right and a
bombshell was dropped oh [__] our
interview oh swoop said Thank You Ethan
Olivia and the whole H3 team for
covering this thank you swoop thank you
thank you absolutely
so there's a bombshell coming up yes so
Johnny oh [__] lets it slip that he was
in uh group chats with minors uh
as well so if you want to click that
with Colleen
with Colleen but we also find some
things out later okay let's see
grooming people love to misconstrue
that's inappropriate
Zach
nobody okay Play It Again Zach um I
thought it's inappropriate I was kidding
it was a joke but I guess it missed the
best because Johnny was so prominent in
the fan base and he worked on Colleen's
tour Johnny actually built a little fan
base of his own really and he had a job
he had Johnny's apple seeds he had a
Johnny fan oh
because he was talking about Corey's
Corey's clits Cory's clits I mean that
is pretty disgusting right but he had
Johnny appleseeds
[Laughter]
yeah that sounds sound good right right
not good no
more you think about it the worse it
gets
[__] me right
you're gonna be like oh no Johnny was in
DMS with minors I was I'll be the first
person to say it all right bro what are
you doing yeah what oh okay why are you
doing this you're burying yourself bro
she talked to his ass for six hours I
think yeah because he just kept going
and kept talking and telling on himself
she's pretty slick that's what they do
in deposition exactly six hours long
amazing you can't go longer because it's
considered like cruel and unusual unless
of course you're interrogating like a uh
a mentally uh
how's what's the nice word
uh neurodivergent yeah like a
neurodivergent uh child then you can
interview them for 48 hours without a
parent involved you know that's what the
police like to do but um in the
depositions
I mean I've only done it once but I know
what the strategy is they fatigue you
for four hours
and then they come at you with the
really hard [__] the last two hours and
your brains and it is true like when
that happened to me
you get fatigued you really do sure but
uh she man she held this [__] together
for a long time and look at look at him
he's spilling like
he's spilling like the Titanic does the
Titanic spill I don't think
I mean they're they had to say they took
a spill
because they had the safety compartments
and they were spilling over totally true
there was water spillage I'm sure and he
is sinking like the Titanic yeah
maybe a stretch
legitimate grooming people love to
misconstrue I'm sure if they're gonna be
like oh no Johnny was in DMS with minors
I was I'll be the first person to say it
I I was in the group that originally was
a Colleen group chat that I had been
added in my friend who I am not friends
with it uh anymore overtook that and
created
group where he decided to start grooming
teenage girls on the internet you know
they were awesome everybody's a groomer
I probably should we're not going to the
next slide yet but the next slide is
about that friend that friend's name is
Tim and they were best friends for a
decade and in that decade they were in
group chats with kids and Johnny alleges
that Tim groomed those kids and also
um swoop said that
it's to remain anonymous but she and her
team think that actual legitimate
grooming took place with Tim in those
chats so Johnny was in a chat with
miners with Josh Colleen him his homie
Tim everybody's grooming not Johnny
everybody is grooming
um
let that first clip
play
that rooms or DMS that I was added to
during tour and it was tricky because I
didn't want to be in VMS with a bunch of
teenage girls like I was you know
confident in my sexuality of anything I
want boys well men I wanted to be in a
group with you that was that was what am
I going to do with underage girls yeah
look at that face it paused on I know
it's happening
what the [__] is happening I like choked
when I heard that the first time
he's such a great frame to pause on
there he's really just did someone give
him a truth serum or something
this man is sinking the boat yikes
listen I was my friend was grooming
girls and that was that was Vibes
I don't want to [__] girls right
so that's why I went and made my own
chat with minor boys crazy
I gotta go back and listen to that again
and you know because I did Ms that I was
uh added to during tour and it was
tricky because I didn't want to be in
VMS with a bunch of teenage girls
because at first I was like okay because
you were an adult right and um it was it
felt inappropriate right but that that's
actually not the take
that I didn't even know that there was a
fork because like the other take I
couldn't even conceive of
yeah
which is like I was you know confident
in myself
well men to be in my DMs now why are we
why are we marrying sexuality with the
idea of group chats with minors good
point
good point
because he's like the only reason
anyone's in these group chats is try to
[__] somebody
to be to be a Stan of somebody and to
own it I guess
sure that's crazy as a reminder John
when he was uh on Colleen Ballinger's
crew back in 2018 when he was at 22. the
end of that clip I wanted you to see if
you want to click the next one
um Johnny based on his own definition of
Grooming
participated
here so because Johnny maybe a little
bit he's very he casts The Grooming that
very broadly it seems sounds like yes
and actually
um
if you ask Johnny
the one where you don't know why they're
grooming is the worst one right that's
the worst one so let's see maybe he's
the worst offender of all older which I
know is a tricky topic too because some
people are like I was 21 and in a group
chat with 17 year old and it's like calm
down you're fine
um the the issue is the power imbalance
that these adults had with us children
just as a reminder Johnny you had a
power imbalance with your underage fans
okay
is Colleen's tour bus that he met fans
outside of he would hold unofficial meet
and greets
oh he did yes
so there was people he had fans yes he
had fans because people knew who he was
because Colleen would Vlog coin did her
shows he was in the shows
I I'm sure I probably knew who he was at
one point okay
and then he's like you only have my own
little fan meetups which is a little
weird yeah
my guy
since it's Thanksgiving I wanted to say
I'm super thankful for the wonderful
people I've met on here I met my best
friends in the whole world and some
amazing people to look up to that I
can't imagine my life without I love you
guys is that him or no that's someone up
these are one of the oh wow these are
really young these girls this is Johnny
with his fans
foreign
a year ago today me and Sam me and Sammy
met Johnny for the first time and
immediately stand him don't even know
where to begin I honestly don't know
where my life would be if I hadn't met
Johnny
and I'm so beyond thankful for him I
can't believe it's been a year
since this amazing yada yada
yeah so if you want to go to the next
slide I'm just gonna keep watching oh
then here's Johnny DM to me so he
reached
okay
let me ask this question in context of
this whole situation okay can an older
person
have an appropriate relationship with a
minor
like at all like let's say Josh was
reaching out because he wanted to Mentor
them and he wanted to take care of that
and Johnny is apparently talking to them
for the same purpose so but then how
somehow it always devolves into grooming
swoop discusses that she talks about how
dangerous it is to cast such a wide net
in terms of the definition of grooming
and um
let me remember what exactly
she says like based on your own
definition
any adult speaking with
someone underage is grooming right and
it but it begs the question I mean is
this relationship ever appropriate right
because I mean it is important for kids
to have role models and people to look
up to
but maybe that intimate a connection is
not is just not appropriate I don't know
yeah and maybe not talking about adult
subjects
with Johnny's apple seeds yeah
dude chill man talking about kids man
that dude is out of pocket
hmm
I mean personally from myself
I would never be in a chat with a child
not a private message with a child or or
if I was it would be very brief and it
would be very like here's the thing I'm
out if they said like hey something's up
I need and if I cared about it it's like
here's the thing I'm out yeah because we
don't have any anything else to talk
about with a baby I wish you the best I
hope you get through it
probably should have kept that to
yourself My Guy totally
but then if there's a kid who really
needs
your house there's got other people in
real life though
well maybe not their big brother
programs and stuff they're not they're
not grooming
well they're they're mentors too that's
see that's tricky because teachers and
people like that they do do that right
but it's it's also different when it's
someone that you watch online and you're
a huge fan of
there's that that Mystique yes
so it's a difficult question I'm not
sure what's the right answer either
but I I know that if anyone pushes it
far I mean that that's that's weird like
to actually I don't know it seems weird
to me
um if you go to the next slide
next slide
so people began
posting on the Colleen snark Reddit
about Johnny and possible allegations
regarding him and due to the Colleen
snark Reddit rules which said like you
cannot disparage any of the victims
coming forward they were taking them
down the mods were taking them down
which that makes total sense so then
Reddit those people went and they
started a new one called truth about
Johnny and um Johnny has his own snark
subreddit yeah so let's talk about what
was brought to light
um so wait where did these people come
from
the Colleen snark right they didn't want
the Johnny snark the well because the
rules in the Colleen snark Reddit are
that you cannot disparage any of the
people coming forward speaking against
okay they want to keep it tight which is
smart which is smart so now we got truth
about Johnny yes so things that swoop
reveals
right now in her video is that Johnny
was in group chats and video chats with
minors for the entirety of his 20s
Johnny
um identifies
to being
um a mentor to his fans he even uses the
word which is very reminiscent of when
he told the story of Josh mentoring him
the worst type of grooming yeah I mean
his words
um
and so something that swoop also
mentioned is that directly following
um the pop-up of this truth about Johnny
Reddit apparently the people that this
Reddit were claiming were Johnny's
victims all reached out to swoop right
away
was like
that was concerning a little bit
huh okay
I'm actually I'm reading interesting
comments because I'm genuinely curious
about what people think about like the
adult oh tell me uh minor
uh
connection
because I do think
it's different than when I was a kid
because we didn't have there was no
social media
that that connection was just not made
but I can imagine how how weird it would
be if a teacher was in my DMs yeah
the teachers aren't in
I'm just trying to think I'm trying to
think of that that kind of relationship
because he's an adult who has holds some
Authority yeah uh maybe not literally
but he has that that power what do you
think Dan
I don't know I need to see more
what about the okay whatever
thank you so I'll watch let's see
video chats Johnny had his own super
fans Johnny built relationships with a
number of minors for years Johnny what
did they get this footage from
the the truth about Johnny read it so
there's people in truth about Johnny who
were and swoop was in contact with some
of the people in Johnny's God this [__]
goes so deep we're in like the tenth
layer of hell right now I know
it's just like bad people breed bad
people at next I don't I honestly I will
never get it
or like 10 chat rooms deep yeah of
Inception
but no so somebody in that saved an
image of it well I mean when you're when
you're doing something fun as a kid and
you're talking to your idol or whatever
you're gonna document it sure yeah
and it was recent enough to where like
they had super easy access to like
Snapchats right stuff right
broken and adults speaking to minors in
group and video chats Johnny had his own
super fans Johnny built relationships
with a number of miners for years Johnny
promised people he had left these group
chats after his employment with Colleen
ended and lied about it Johnny has
spoken to these fans publicly and
privately and had Secrets dude
somebody's got mad receipts on him yeah
this is way more receipts than at
Colleen or Josh or Corey's clits no in
terms of like the chat room stuff I
guess this is like 20 different chat
rooms that's true
I mean okay let me walk that back I
don't mean like receipts no in terms of
like visuals yeah and visual like
someone record like documented so many
of these
it's with them for years but on top of
all of that Johnny has given his fans so
much attention both publicly and
privately he's very committed to keeping
the specifics of those relationships a
secret at least two of his fans had the
immediate reaction to try to get me to
keep parts of this story a secret
programming manipulation
tactics love bombing words of
affirmation they use towards people when
they're in sticky situations that make
these people feel good and inclined to
go online and fight for them so I just
want to ask a very simple question based
on Johnny's very own flexible definition
of grooming as well as the actual
definition of grooming who in the story
I'm telling today fits the bill on both
let me know your thoughts in the
comments girl you know the answer yeah
we love you swoop
um
he really he really put himself in the
corner yeah I mean he spent this whole
time being like everybody's a groomer
damn bro it's just a few little
self-awareness yeah that you're involved
in all of this [__] why not keep your
mouth he came out dude he did this to
himself yeah that's what I'm saying he's
like came out and he just
wow
so what was that she she kind of glossed
over people he used to talk with here if
you go to the next one that's
came and said don't include a few of
these pieces please
oh that part was that um the Reddit was
alleging
three
victims and two of those people messaged
swoop right away victims of what victims
of being in minors being uh in like
video chats when they were minors and
like in group chats when they were
minors with John the worst form of
grooming according to according that's
what they say that's what they say
okay and so two of the three immediately
reached out to her yeah and said what
well she didn't say exactly what they
said
um she said they are she said they urged
her to to keep part of it a secret in
the story civil definition of grooming
very good and inclined to and there are
ticks of this story it had the immediate
reaction to try to get me to keep parts
of this story a secret
what I interpreted that as like they're
embarrassed maybe and they don't want
people to know yeah maybe
less but could mean that they're trying
to defend him I don't know it's a little
cryptic yeah
so the next slide is about Tim Connolly
this is Johnny's
ex-best friend of 10 years they are no
longer Associated
um but something we know about Tim is
that he would host group video calls
with his minor fans ranging 13 to 15
years old where he would get drunk he
would encourage them to drink ah no and
he would teach them about sex he
apparently what still hangs out with
minors his minor fans to this day
um and swoop says that it had to remain
anonymous but her team thinks that he is
an actual Predator based on things that
have been shared with well we're talking
about Johnny's bestie Yeah Tim and then
those video chats swoop uh swoop found
out that Johnny would be present for at
least a year he was on those video calls
with his friend Tim
um as recently as 2020 which is when he
was 24 years old and then is Tim getting
access to these
to these miners via Johnny well he was a
prominent person in Colleen's fandom as
well dude this is this is like the
Catholic church at this point it's crazy
what is this photo too something that
she says I don't know he's giving him
the the choir board Mark yeah um but
does compare Johnny to jalaine Maxwell
swoop Compares Johnny to G Lane Maxwell
wait who's the episode
is Tim yes this kid
okay that was the comparison made I see
what she means though he he he's
he gets him leads yeah
yo this whole Colleen Empire is crazy
[__] up and you got Tim
Connolly down at the bottom yes I'm in
drunk parties this part of the video I
encourage you if you're confused um you
should definitely go watch because swoop
has she did so much work it's crazy
that's actually good because the next
section is the Josh section and then
we're done okay we're back it's the big
circle I'm not taking a pause to pee
take a brief intermission I suppose
um there was a somebody earlier who I
wanted to thank who donated a hundred
memberships to the to the channel wow um
earlier but we were in the midst of
talking about all this where is it where
is it where is it where is it past Chris
Christie
here we go Aspen's so awesome Aspen so
awesome thank you if you're still
watching sorry we didn't acknowledge it
earlier oh wow swoop says Johnny posted
that he would bring Colleen's fans to
Tim
so pretty he just admitted it pretty
much
huh wait say that again Johnny posted
that he would bring Colleen's fans to
Tim
okay so maybe the just Lane thing does
uh yeah that sounds pan out line up
it is pretty [__] insane
um let's see what else we got oh there
was somebody else oh right
um the guy from The Tiger Stadium uh
donated 50 bucks Brandon here it is
Brandon Cardenas the Tigers production
guy
and there was an event happening on The
Concourse so I promise people heard it
and shout out to AB and Lena from
Detroit go Tigers thank you Brandon whoa
thank you play some Zach Lewis next time
yeah thank you Cam appreciate that buddy
Zach did his uh show at the soda room
this past weekend and we rocked him like
a hurricane
did you get it I get it did you play
that song no I did not play
why not Aura was in the set
uh what is this Dono 20 bucks breaking
news Johnny Silvestri first man ever to
lay down with dogs and come up with no
fleas
what oh because
right because everybody was grooming but
him right I was uh
uh Dan can you tell me I'm cool please
I'm having a bad day and need a
pick-me-up go lucky Arrow wait we're
having a bad day for her he's so cool
you're so cool he's so cool let's see
what's going on with go lucky Arrow
what is this uh what is this profile
picture
that's the profile picture of a cool guy
or a girl very cool cool person
anybody identify what this is
wait hold up just a man like feeling it
he's just feeling it oh this is like a
stock photo it's just a hassle hope
oh is it Hasselhoff yeah I think you're
right good eyes Zaki good eye all right
well shout out you're very cool you
gotta have that profile picture thank
you love you buddy
and we're going for the Long Haul so I
gotta you know I mean I gotta empty the
blast I feel you yeah yeah it's not easy
all right so we are talking about Tim oh
this is just that is we're done talking
about Tim do we have any receipts about
Tim how what do we know about Tim there
I'll be honest I was a bit confused I
really encourage you to watch he sounds
like a horrible guy who is a predator
and talks to minors and still hangs out
with minors so swoosh has more receipts
swoosh does swoosh swoosh but it does
have more information sorry girl sorry
girl it was Ethan's fault
um I'll take that yeah
yeah no uh swoop has spoken with some of
Tim's alleged victims anonymously
um
so why aren't we talking about Tim
Johnny
that's the question right right right
right right
why aren't we talking about Johnny
Johnny why are we talking about Johnny
Johnny yeah
okay all right so now
let's talk about Johnny's life ruining
accusations against Joshua Evans Colleen
Ballinger's ex-husband if you don't know
who he is
excellent
this is the first tweet where Johnny
accuses Josh of grooming him
so this was a big deal yes
and I remember it kind of blew all of
our minds because we're like Colleen
her best friend
they're all in chats and then when you
learn like her husband who it just all
starts to get really bizarre
Johnny says
I was groomed by Josh as a teen
and then they literally ended up doing
almost the exact same [__] he did to me
wait I'm confused by the he's talking
about like Adam's story they did the
exact same [__] to me he's saying
they are no different and there's so
much more behind all of this it was over
a decade of manipulation and torment for
multiple sources and that's just my
story
so there's that one pretty cryptic right
then Josh messages Johnny an apology
if you would like to read it this is
interesting
and then he publishes the apology to
give his story credibility you want me
to read it go ahead okay
um I was in the wrong you felt abandoned
or disregarded that's the honest truth I
never would have done it just for
clarity Johnny's
um
final like communication with Josh was
that after the divorce apparently his
mentor man who was grooming him totally
ghosted him and left him okay so I was
in the wrong Josh says you felt
abandoned or disregarded that's the
honest truth I never would have done it
if I fully understood how it would end
up your heart mattered then and instead
of handling it head on I thought you'd
lose interest and move to something else
that was incredibly wrong on my part you
were young and deserved transparency and
protection I straddled the fence on
being like an internet big brother to
you and also feeling like he was
becoming unhealthy for your well-being
and development hold on that's a that's
an interesting admission yeah
are
our relationship was unhealthy for your
well-being I think that because swoop
does do
um a bit of investigating about their
relationship and how close they really
were I don't based on what swoop is
found it seems that they were not super
close
um I think that
I think that Josh is validating Johnny's
feelings in this message I think that I
think that this was
in good
you know what I mean good faith yeah so
it could be construed as Josh just
trying to keep this kid
who's showing a lot of interest in him
at arm's length
okay
[Music]
it's gonna raise anything that you felt
or went through I thought you were a
great kid you seemed a lot like I was as
a teen so it felt okay to befriend you
it wasn't okay I should have never
interacted with you beyond some tweets
and saying hi edit meet and greets you
deserve a happy and healthy Future
Johnny I played a role in messing some
of that up my hope is that this apology
helps you see that you were never in the
wrong you wanted a friend that's it I
gave you the illusion that I could be
that friend which at the time I
genuinely thought I could be until I
began to realize that the amount of
attachment that you were feeling
interesting yes
no you'll you'll it's blue because swoop
is in Communications with Josh
um so I mean yeah I can see this like
definitely if we're being as charitable
as possible to Josh
as like
he saw this and he's genuinely like wow
I didn't know that he was like it was
that serious but I you know I want to
apologize yes if that if for how it made
you feel that's what it seems to me at
least and also he ends by saying I
generally thought I could be until I
realized the amount of attachment that
you're feeling
and also I mean it could mean that Josh
was was responsibly keeping this kid at
arm's length and we actually we will see
there's there's okay you'll see so but
the fact that Johnny
uh published this to give because this
basically when we saw this we're like oh
everything he's saying is true hmm right
or I do remember being like Oh Josh is
apologizing yeah so what did he do
and Johnny okay interesting right okay
so Johnny continues accusing Josh
vehemently of being a groomer not
letting up here he says just as bad if
not worse than Colleen he doesn't get a
free pass just because he's been doing
everything in his power to save face
it's uh Joshua after the divorce left
YouTube he posted a few times like over
quarantine and stuff like that but he he
really ended his YouTube career with the
divorce
um so I don't know what he means by he's
getting a free pass to save face um
everyone's forgiving him on my behalf
and it's pretty disheartening I don't
forgive him well yet at least hmm
curious so again he's he's laying it on
real thick so then
um Johnny posted how dare you call me
vindictive at Joshua After all you've
put me through how dare you and Josh
responds and then includes the
attachment where he does called Johnny
vindictive in their DMS but he was okay
he has been being vindictive the
question is is it warranted or not he is
being vindictive there's no question
about it right sometimes it's warranted
but so what Johnny does here
he says just as bad if not worse than
Colleen
when I read that I'm hearing that
something terrible happened that's also
what I assumed because how could he be
worse
okay Joshua said I did my voice was
taking me from taken from me years ago I
was silenced and threatened repeatedly I
faced my mistakes daily and have worked
on myself I will continue to do so that
being said I will not be silenced again
my heart goes out to you Johnny I also
deserve to protect my new life
hmm
more yes so this is the this is after
the first apology that Josh sends now he
sends Johnny I truly understand your
anger this is getting vindictive I lost
everything and it's taken me years and
years to slowly build my life back up
from nothing into something worth living
for I never once had intentional
malicious intentions back then or now my
apology was sincere not perfect but
sincere the Internet isn't my life
anymore it's not my job I have a quiet
little life and have been working so
hard on myself to be okay after all the
trauma I personally went through he
dealt with um
alcoholism and is now sober
congratulations
um death threats targeted bullying for
years they even went after my little
sister I lost a career and my self-worth
I was suicidal and dragged through the
mud for so long that doesn't negate your
life and how you feel and I'm not saying
this to erase your experience I just
don't understand why you choose to go
this route toward me specifically I
never went after you or anything
remotely close to that my divorce my
parents sudden divorced the alcoholism
took over my life I didn't want to live
anymore I'm far from perfect but man I'm
trying so once again
I'm assuming
that Johnny posted these
um
and it seems like he's not responding to
him actually Josh posted this publicly
oh Josh posted this one okay interesting
uh go ahead
um okay what I you'll see he the next
one he does publicly is just like I'm
just gonna do this publicly to remain
transparent I want everyone to see it
um so then he said what they did to you
and to me was absolutely terrible I
played a part but not to mold control or
abuse you you may not see that right now
but I'm doing my best to speak honestly
I should have reached out to you earlier
I was experiencing my own trauma and
barely made it out alive I don't say
that lightly it's just the truth after
years of suffering healing and growth
I'm here trying my best I finally
crawled out of such a dark place a place
that almost killed me I'm human Johnny I
didn't do things the right way at times
but I never intended to hurt you ever my
entire life went up in flames in more
ways than I ever want to divulge Why Try
to burn it down all over again
I definitely feel like what he's saying
is true about himself yeah
but also understand how tricky it is
for
Josh to tell all this to Johnny
when you're assuming that he's in good
faith
you know sharing his experience how do
you how do you
how do you approach that it's very
difficult yeah I can imagine yeah
so Josh posted this so yes and then Josh
posts this public one he tags Johnny he
says Johnny I'm doing this publicly to
remain transparent I owe you an apology
you were young when I thought I could
Mentor you in a positive way I should
have never given you my number that was
inappropriate I shouldn't have asked you
to tweet on my Sarah account that was
his like little character that he had
okay those those are inappropriate
relationships it felt harmless and I
understand now that that was a mistake I
made a lot of mistakes back then I'm so
sorry for ever making you feel
disregarded and tossed to the side my
life was toxic and chaotic for a long
time I was toxic I was chaotic you were
young and needed consistency and
protection I did not give that to you
your pain is real your healing journey
is real My Hope Is that I can help
remove some of the burden by
acknowledging her experience and taking
accountability I'm sorry Johnny not for
wanting to be your friend an internet
big brother but for failing at it and
walking away in the way that I did I
hope in time you feel Vindicated in at
peace regardless of how you feel towards
me I only wish the best for your future
Josh so what was the response when he
posted this he was angry he was just
like no like the people's response yeah
the the people's response how did people
respond to this oh people were like
people didn't really know because we
didn't know what probably were probably
telling him to [__] off I'm sure that
there were there was a countless amount
of people telling him to [__] off I
remember just being very confused
because he's a Paul he keeps apologizing
so you're assuming something yeah you
know something happened
uh more tweets from Johnny Joshua
groomed me with Colleen I was 15 when
this all started they double timed me I
was hit from both sides any OG fan knows
this they all saw the strange dynamic
they had with me the more that comes out
the better you'll understand thanks for
your patience
yeah and then uh if you want to watch
the link on this is just like what he
proceeded to do when he went on a bunch
of different places so with all of that
context in mind let's look at what
Johnny proceeded to do over the course
of the following month and a half Johnny
made YouTube videos posted on Tick Tock
held Instagram lives and every day he
tweeted many sometimes even dozens of
times about Joshua David Evans you've
ended up wow
on the H3 podcast in my opinion
manipulating Olivia Ethan and Ela who
has those people that's us
you look so cute H3 podcast or vh3
podcast that's right let's work to try
to cover this story and support the
victims he told his story to me as well
and he reached out to Lily and Jesse of
the do we know them podcast asking if
they would like to interview him look
Mom I'm on a podcast
um not a great Vibe yeah
um so if you go to the next slide now
during this time Johnny was suspended
for 24 hours on his new account he was
banned from his previous Instagram
account and has now been okay
next one so the Bell is ringing after
swoops six hour interview with Johnny
she reconvened with her team
they met they talked about everything
she uh this this photo no I'm just more
of the graphic thank you
swoop Colin will you answer answer that
[__] are you gonna would you answer it
I'm not getting on a call with swoop for
six hours you're gonna turn my life
upside down I'm like man that was a
great call
that was an incredible call
um Okay so uh dude he must have been so
blindsided by her video so in this WOW
in this phone call swoop tells Johnny
everything that she knows she knows that
he was in group chats with kids she
knows second call yes this is the second
call this is yes she is asking him this
is July 20th 2023. she calls Johnny she
asks him what he wants to do about the
fact that she knows these things about
him he responds to her access to Live
show tickets
sorry guys
Okay so
no no go back yeah I want to see
um so he tells swoop that he knows that
being in those chats was inappropriate
and wrong
um when swoop asks him about taking
accountability he said that too much
attention would would be aimed at him
and away from the cooling victims and
then that's when swoop decided she was
gonna make this is there
audio of this it's jump it's like so
there is audio of this there is and I
encourage you to watch it okay yeah it's
I'm consolidating stuff
um so in in defense of himself he says
it's not about me it's about them right
essentially right which is
uh definitely a red flag considering
he's speaking so broadly about
things that he's doing and then what
he's doing it's not a problem only when
they're doing it yes so it's very
interesting she asks him what he wants
to do about that and she also asks him
for full transcripts of all of his
messages with Josh oh yes after this
call swoop says that Johnny does not
tweet about Josh again oh
and after some hesitation Johnny does in
fact send swoop his transcripts he did
he does how does she know that oh [__]
dude this is next level I know what's
happening yeah so what Johnny did not
know is that um if you click the first
clip swoop also asked Josh to send his
Twitter
yo you just got [__] he sent it right
away
yo that's crazy so Joshua sent his
transcripts right away that's fire and
history
[Music]
two
this is crazy it's so sad it's just it's
so satisfying when you can for sure you
know this is the truth this is the swoop
this is the swoof because you know John
you compare them yep
slick
I love that slickness me too all right
so I'm gonna click the first link yes
oh hold on girl for his Twitter DM
history with Johnny but I did about it
the last thing I didn't have to tell
Johnny but I did and so when I asked
Josh for his Twitter DM history with
Johnny he sent me a screen recording
from top to bottom of 20 total DMS
between 2012 and 2016 when they had
stopped speaking 14 of those messages
were from Johnny to Joshua and the
remaining six messages were replies from
Joshua that's it it's not a lot were
they communicating in other ways
he says that they were also texting but
swoop poses she thinks that this is
either all of the messages that they've
exchanged and the rest is public on
Twitter or they have very few texts
[Music]
um
okay I mean if there was a significant
amount of other Communications I I
assume one of them would have brought it
up there are more doctor texts there are
yes okay so we're looking at DMS
um yeah let's watch the first one first
okay okay answering two of Johnny's
questions meaning Joshua only ever
answered Johnny twice in four years once
to a public question Johnny asked him on
Twitter and the other to a question
about a show that Joshua was playing the
entire exchange also began with Johnny
initiating the conversation by telling
Joshua that he was depressed and in need
of guidance back in December one more
time how old is Johnny during this
like when he says I'm depressed that's
the first message he sent him
see a minor or C let me make sure an
adult
oh I can pull it up you want me well I
can do the math to see how old Johnny
was because he's 27 now in 2023. it says
uh February uh 2014 seems to be the
first one here okay at least that she's
showing
or well hold on this is no no no this is
December 2012.
2012. yeah December 2012.
so he was 16. okay
okay so he is he's very young
okay that's good to know
screen recording from top to bottom of
20 total DMS between 2012 and 2016. I
think okay
that's a big difference 14 of those
messages were from Johnny to
by the time the first thing 18. it was
well that was by the time that they
stopped talking so yeah I was talking
about in the beginning he was 16. he met
them in person for the first time when
he was 15. and then I guess they began
on Twitter when he was okay Joshua and
the remaining six messages were replies
from Joshua answering two of Johnny's
questions meaning Joshua only ever
answered Johnny twice in four years once
to a public question Johnny asked him on
Twitter and the other to a question
about a show that Joshua was playing the
entire exchange also began with Johnny
initiating the conversation by telling
Joshua that he was depressed okay he's
16 though like let's you know what I
mean and in need of guidance back in
December of 2012 which was although it's
a call for help I guess I see the point
I mean you know that that's
you know
yeah
it makes it more likely that you know
he's going to care and want to help very
upsetting and sad to see I never want to
see somebody depressed now Joshua did
not respond which is not at all what I
expected after talking to Johnny for six
hours about this I was expecting to see
like tons of just back and forth message
exchanges since Johnny said that they
had a tight-knit relationship can you
tell me about how how many times you
would estimate that you hung out with
Josh in person he would say stuff to me
like oh my God come to California uh
come to California for my show and I'd
be like are you serious you'd be like
yeah come on down and I'd be like whoa
sick you can ask anybody he would be
like oh yeah me and Johnny we're gonna
take over the world we're gonna make it
big together someday this guy is so cool
and so that's so that's how he what he's
saying is sounds really [__] up right
um if you the second clip but also
sounds almost cartoonishly yeah we're
gonna make it me and you
yeah to the top
he hesitates for a while
um after swoop asks him the first time
to send transcripts of his messages with
Josh selfless like what a good person
Johnny has accused Joshua of grooming
and being a pressure worse than Colleen
those are serious [__] allegations is
Josh someone that you would turn to with
personal things like yourself yeah and
then you guys started texting like on a
one-on-one basis not super regularly
because I didn't want to abuse it I
didn't want to lose this privilege
because they like gave you little things
but then would kind of hold it over your
head even if they didn't say it to your
face now Johnny did say the majority of
their relationship was held publicly
over Twitter
doesn't seem like they knew each other
much at all
like at all
which is why when he got that apology
from Josh I feel like it was
so important to his narrative
to post that all right number two
using this right now as they see this
wait that was a sick graphic
telling Johnny that Joshua had already
sent a copy neither of them knew about
the other to keep it clean and I'm sure
they're both realizing this right now as
they see this now Johnny hesitated at
first Joshua did not and Johnny asked me
what exactly I was looking for which I
thought was odd and I said that I wanted
to see if Joshua said anything
inappropriate in those messages uh
Johnny said okay and we ended the call
then he texted me something weird he
said can I see DMS If I blocked someone
no he just got home do you happen to
know if you lose your DMs with the
person if you have them blocked
right he already knew the answer to this
so we felt like he was maybe buying time
or thinking of a reason why he couldn't
send them or why he's going to erase
some of them
right I was blocked at the time that was
followed by wait never mind and a few
minutes later he sent screenshots but
when I received them multiple DMS were
actually missing on Johnny's screens
that weight never mind
you about to get swooped
I can't wait to see what these were
swoop text me swoop there it is Swoop
there it is Swoop there it is we believe
that's the moment that he realized he
could manipulate the messages allegedly
we believe that based on this
information that Johnny Silvestri likely
deleted most of his own messages
significantly altering his actual
conversations with Josh making it look
like Josh was highly engaged in dming
him when in fact most of the time it was
Johnny sending messages with no reply
this is something that Johnny has chosen
not to share with the public why now
wait is she not showing the ones he
erased
like kind of goes through it it's not
important it he basically does it to to
make it seem like he wasn't badgering
Josh it was a lot of like hey can I
please talk to you hey are you free can
I talk to you hello right it was a lot
of that um if you go to the third
because I was curious and I don't know
if I'm the only one but I kind of wanted
to read through these and there's not
that much of them
uh of the DMs
especially all of the communication or
what about the group chat so like well
no Josh wasn't in group chats I don't
think so Josh wasn't in there I think
this is all yeah of all of it this is
supposedly all of it plus their texts
which he admitted to Ethan that there
are not very there's not a lot and if
Johnny and if this is a lot and then
Johnny says the text Arnold the third
clip is not the text did they meet in
person
um okay so we have the text too yes we
do we have some and their doctored
um
right so uh his family actually drove
nine hours to an auto show that Josh was
doing to surprise him
and then there they filmed a video for
Josh's Channel where they're like all
dancing the Harlem shake like his family
he didn't invite them no they surprised
him dancing the Harlem Shake man if my
kid asked me to drive nine hours to
surprise an influencer
I'd have to have a sit-down conversation
that's that's pretty wild but yeah no
he's he the two times they hung out it
was like he surprised him
so just to get an idea I'm kind of
curious
Josh how did you get through your high
school years I feel like I'm falling
apart there's just too much stress and
I'm depressed
now this was blurred it's an email I
think okay uh
here is uh Josh
wanted to answer your Tweet privately
the answer is no I have a major
opportunity starting in January the auto
show announcement will come soon 20
total DMS between 2012 and 20. okay
can't wait to hear about it hey I have
some questions for you I was going to
surprise you and show up
on Friday oh so you did tell him about
it but I don't have an address well it's
not a surprise then well he was gonna
surprise 16 when they had stopped he
gave him the address
clarifying about a show you're going woo
okay so I mean it's less weird and then
uh a story that he told on the show was
that he went to LA to a show to see Josh
and he came out to him there and then he
basically tells him like that's none of
my business don't tell your parents I
remember so he said that he was 17 when
that happened right he was 19. okay
right I remember that was a big stick
that's a big difference
also clarifies his birthday and
clarifies that that trip took place when
he was of age
Johnny says yes I'm going I wanted to
surprise you but I didn't know where to
go so that could have failed big time at
all 14 of those messages how long is the
show half an hour buddy hour and a half
buddy from Johnny to Joshua what's the
difference between me just making videos
right now and me signing up to be a
partner with a company like full screen
six messages were replied doesn't answer
hey would you be able to go to hang out
after the show tonight
even just go eat or something would be
fun Joshua answering two no response hey
can I tell you something these questions
I need to talk to you urgently why what
you know if I was Josh I would have just
put this out and be like I don't know
what this kid is talking about because
looking at these this man was like
keeping him at a responsible arm's
length
what it seems it seems like that yeah
that because he was like dude this is
basically what I got from Joshua that's
what I yeah like no no
keeping the answer short
minuscule yes
he acting like an adult you shouldn't
have given him the number right that was
a mistake that was
okay this is [__] real interesting
um the third link is it's all very
complicated but you watch swoop do her
like CIA figuring out I like that yeah I
love that part whoops good at that [__]
yeah she's the best and we know she's
the best
not yeah okay so we're going back to the
PowerPoint where are we the second video
what Johnny didn't know the third link
third link yes okay I had run Twitter
accounts for him that he encouraged and
he asked me to run for him I just found
the text message where he
this I have a question because he was
running a social media he was running
just as Sarah ridiculous so Josh created
his version of a Miranda Sings that he
was like dabbling with called Sarah
diculous it didn't really go anywhere
God they're duplicating it was it was it
was pretty little Jesus he didn't make
very many videos of it but he had Johnny
run that Twitter account and Johnny quit
the day after or two days after they
announced their divorce yo somebody
pointed out you gave everybody your
number Ethan yeah oh actually and I even
I did answer a call once too oh no wow
although it did sound like an adult
someone called I was like Yo dude stop
why are you calling me right I remember
what the [__] leave me alone but I was
an adult I think though I can never
confirm it true
I guess according to
uh
Johnny
that's the worst type of grooming you
did a Johnny Johnny no papa
um Eddie said that Johnny Johnny no papa
so there's got to be a conversation
about him asking him to do a social
media where is that conversation
[Music]
missing pieces coming up well it's like
he says that he found that text and then
that is like
spark something in swoop she's like you
found that text that means that you have
at least some because you said that you
you don't
right
he asked me to run the account so when I
asked Johnny if he could send me the
text messages between him and Josh about
the Sarah ridiculous account he sent me
a screenshot of his old computer with I
think your humor is awesome and I don't
have a lot of time to run that account I
love for you to tweet as Sarah
ridiculous as much as you'd like if
that's okay you'd use your own judgment
to follow people and tweet thoughts I
mean that's pretty insane thing to ask
it is a little crazy right definitely
yeah yeah for a child yeah 15 15 year
old child yeah yeah thank you very much
I'm sure
he would I'm not going to speak for Josh
I think he would admit it he basically
said it but so um Johnny said yeah that
sounds like fun just let me know when
you would want me to start login
password you can start now if you'd like
why what the [__] that's it I mean like
what is Josh was this Sarah ridiculous
thing just like a
goof it was just like nothing it was
just like was it nothing or was it
something because it has like a hundred
followers it was pretty much like NADA
why is it Miranda interested in some in
just this random teenager
it seems like it could not have been
very important but still why are these
people so weird
man I was such a big fan I had never
heard of Sarah diculus actually so I
never even knew what this was no I did
not know if Olivia doesn't know what it
is it must have been it must have been
very under the radar it's still very
it's still weird yeah right people know
it's him yeah yeah right so it's still
His Image yeah for sure
this kid to just work for you for free
if anything I just see Josh like
actually
the small amount of communication so
small amount from Josh like hey here's
the thing here's the password go work
for me it's like it's a little exploity
yeah sure and all but the actually
what's exploiting about it is like
Johnny wants more intimacy
and Joshua is not giving him what he
wants right only having him work but you
could do this [__] yeah yeah yeah
if anything it shows a lack of intimacy
it's giving him like a little bit of
Hope though right it's leading him on
yeah true I think so and also didn't he
start working for them for real later
too he started working for Colleen after
the divorce that's weird after the
divorce and he was of age
he didn't work for Josh
I would like to speculate something
and uh just hit the button if it's
inappropriate oh that kind of
speculation okay but but uh it seems to
me that Johnny
is in love that is or I don't know in
love but he's infatuated with uh I have
a slide on that
it does have Echoes of that doesn't it
it feels like he's like come meet up
with me just the two of us the um he
came out to him which I feel like was
like are you also it was kind of the
Johnny Rock Reddit beliefs that theory
that that makes the most sense to me
that kind of offers an explanation why
it went so hard too this is kind of like
a scorned
unrequited love thing there's if you
want to just go to that slide now and
watch that clip uh that is like the most
I can say it could also explain why Josh
was so weird about the coming out thing
maybe because he's like oh God is this
is maybe what he said something like
that he was interested in him and who
knows what happened in that conversation
that's no this is a valid it's a valid
question
is Josh did he respond to you
let's see Joshy boy that is one I would
love to ask him about what happened
there
[Music]
um
but didn't
deserve Johnny yeah the problem is yes
that like you said love he is he is
leading him on he's not giving him
romantic leading them he I mean it's
possible I don't I doubt Josh even
thought oh this kid is you know into me
but he is making giving him like hope
yeah that their relationship can grow
if you just do free work for me it's
pretty wild it's just not answered yet
Josh come on dude I know you're watching
I mean
if he was sincere in that apology it
sounds like he's pretty
out on being a public YouTube figure he
might have hesitation about coming on
there's a little bit he does a he did an
interview with swoop that's not it's not
out yet but we have he expressed
interest in being on the show that's why
oh he initiated yeah oh okay never mind
he said something like it'd be nice if
he could come because you know he really
got [__] by all this got it God got it
so I would love
to talk with Josh
all right if you want to go to the next
but it also seems like Josh has matured
a lot and you know he's he's owning
yeah the parts with the social media we
read the apology I was confused because
it was like it does like you guys
pointed out it seems like the Johnny guy
kind of used the apology as a way to
boost his claims or everything but the
but the there was nothing in the apology
that really seemed directed towards the
grooming stuff but the exploiting his
enthusiasm as a fan and he touched on
the two things that I have a problem
with which is the phone number and the
social media right yeah which those yeah
that definitely cross lines there
this is very this is where where Ethan
is so lost no I'm not
I am not no I think you seem pretty
informed so far come on where we're at
I'll talk about me like that
all right keep watching keep watching
the CIA clip okay okay okay
interesting detail from the chat about
the Sarah ridiculous account however you
spell that there was a parity account
and Josh wanted whoever ran that to run
his Sarah ridiculous account that person
happened to be Johnny Johnny had a Sarah
ridiculous parody according to this
chatter yes and so and apparently but
from what we sound he was the only
person following Sarah
[Laughter]
yeah
and it seems yeah it seems to me
that that I mean it's still not a good
decision that makes it make more sense
yeah Lisa explains some motive
um
but it seems like and this is just what
I'm speculating with incomplete uh facts
still
that Josh was in good faith trying to
validate
um Johnny's feelings and those apologies
and then
Johnny
really exploited those
it's very interesting so I'll keep
watching this one yeah okay
just open in the background and a shot
of their text exchange about Sarah D but
then my team and I noticed that the open
text window he's showing has an iPhone
file name at the top indicating that
this was a screenshot that was taken
with his phone which then made us think
he has access to his old messages with
swoop
Josh on his phone took a screenshot of
it put it on his old computer and then
took a photo of it all together to make
it look like he can only access it on
his old computer not his phone then we
looked even closer the iMessage window
that is open behind it that has the
exact same this is me right now watching
her explain
look like Donna yeah I'm doing the Donna
the screenshot of the Sarah D
conversation in his messages with a
larger blue bubble under it meaning
Johnny has sent this same screenshot of
his messages with Josh to someone else I
don't know who doesn't matter swoop
but I still couldn't shake the suspicion
that he's lying about having easy access
to all of his old messages so I looked
even closer okay so stay with me okay
detective swoop okay we're doing this so
when you I'm with you girl um right now
I'm with locked in I am I'm locked in
girl I'm with you forever
shot he sent you you see this shape it's
a dark silhouette of a tree on a
mountain how do I know this and then who
walks in she's brilliant no there's no
such thing as a coincidence
it's a picture of him in the background
10 years before Tick Tock existed
he's a time traveling to Empire
you did not hold on let me go back one
more time
not right now just the El capitanus
a detective swoop okay we're doing this
so but when you zoom in on the
screenshot he sent you can see this
shape it's a dark silhouette of a tree
Mountain how do I know this because it's
the default Mac L Capitan operating
system desktop image I'm a thorough
[__] and I remember
[Music]
I love that
remember when I saw this before in
Johnny's post of the Trisha Paytas nude
pics that he made on Twitter when you
zoom in you can see that identical tree
shape in the desktop background and the
iMessages bar has the same green half
gradient at the top I believe these to
be the messages displayed on that same
old computer now here's where my things
get really just yeah John told me that
keep going he had sent a private apology
video to Ella apologizing who's Ella
Ella is the girl who um Johnny alleged
Colleen said was taking her illness to
get close to her
do you remember that say that again it's
one of Colleen's fans was is chronically
ill and Colleen apparently
would say like she's faking it to stay
close to me
and the Johnny and actually the way that
Johnny let that information slide was
also insensitive he just posted it
publicly for Ella to find out right I
remember yeah at the time people were
angry yeah like gee whoa [__] yeah
like you didn't how did that make her
feel suddenly without even asking her
true yep
so did Colleen actually say that though
I mean she did have a character yes in
her podcast she said that she knew
people like that I don't know if it was
about Ella but she said that she knew
people like that okay okay I'm just
gonna watch bullying Ella behind her
back I asked to verify it and he sent me
two clips the first was him filming a
computer that had the old messages
pulled up where he's scrolling through
the messages and giving commentary to
Ella about those messages this was odd
because in the video the computer is
clearly different it looks to be like an
iMac or at least an Apple display and
you can see the background is different
that's a sandy beach scene with sand at
the bottom and clear blue water at the
top and the iMessages window is in dark
mode not the white iMessages window from
his previous screenshots which means in
my opinion Johnny Silvestri not only has
access to his old text messages on his
old computer he also has instant access
on his newer computer which he's never
claimed gives him any trouble
furthermore this would also mean that
Johnny Silvestri would also likely have
access to his old messages on his phone
because it's Apple just log in a perfect
example of this can be seen in Johnny's
Ella story in those screenshots that he
tweeted okay so he said me and Colleen
used to Colleen used to talk [__] about
Ella
now that whole conversation is in
question still there are screenshots
where she's making fun of like her
editing on Instagram
and stuff like that in those screenshots
I'm pretty sure she's like the freckles
they're there and then they're not she's
like making fun of her
zoom in
it's right there dude
wouldn't be funny if swoop edited this
dude it's not there yo look who it is yo
what who is that
who is that
no there's no such thing as a
coincidence
oh my god did I ever tell you that I saw
him at the Grove I walked right past him
he was wearing his hat of course he was
he I think he just saw my eyes go like
and then he just kept walking
dude I knew he was a [__] time
traveling vampire
holy [__]
I can't think about Johnny anymore
those were from his newer computer they
have the same what happened
Okay sandy beach scene that matches this
video that he allegedly sent Ella
privately these tweets were not from his
old computer and they happened to have
older time stamps than the screenshots
that he sent me of his old computer
messages like literally newer messages
are showing up on the old computer and
older messages are showing up on the new
computer make it make sense so all I can
think at this point is that he can get
the old [__] on a new machine so 10 days
after Johnny sent me the Sarah D
screenshot I had a phone call with
Johnny and I asked him if he could send
me his text messages with Josh and he
blamed the old computer again
all right so but did we ever get the
Ella conversation that it's not it's it
wasn't super I mean it was it was
horrible but it's not super relevant to
just because it is really demon [__]
what Colleen to make fun to be like
she's faking it to get close to me he
said there's she said that
he does say that she said that but
there's no proof of it no he said in a
text to Ella that he sent and then it
was published he said that she was
writing a screenplay about a girl got it
yeah and it was supposedly based on her
that's so mean of him to do to her
Ella that is
all right are we swooping continue to
swoop
yes let's continue
and It's tricky because oh [__]
what I have a call with my uh my uh
hematologist at four
he's really fast
oh boy
I did
I was hearing about this for the first
time well I didn't expect that we'd be
in having so much expect that we would
I didn't know this was going to be such
a swoopy scoop
um basically if you were confused by
that section uh very quickly it was all
to show that swoop was able to determine
that Johnny was editing screenshots when
he was sending them to her and he was
not being truthful about what he had
access to wait how did editing it how
like when he that same green bar thing
he was using the same the same like
stencil for his first screenshots
and he had he had different screenshots
from different computers where he said
that like I don't have access
that's pretty shady dear johno the last
time I talked to my hematologist it was
like for um literally two minutes
so do you guys want to listen that's
such a bad idea oh yeah I know thanks
for watching everyone no but I'm not
gonna end it I'm not gonna end it
[Music]
I gotta talk to my doctor I I agree but
you scheduled it for four o'clock no
that's fine I did it weeks ago these
people are hard to get oh so you're on
their timetable I'm on their timetable
okay I mean that makes it a little yeah
I didn't I didn't ask yo can you call me
in the middle of my show
with 66 000 people watching all right
you guys want to hear me with my doctor
no no no no no is it illegal it might
break
everything's an awesome book I'll read
some super chats or something you go
make the call I don't know about that
Dan can we do a poll I can't imagine
anything he could possibly say well he
they don't consent to being on the
stream either right that's what I was
curious yeah baby it's just what about
his hippo rights his hip are rights yeah
we gotta consider the doctor let's do a
poll though
if we should
secretly record this doctor yeah you
probably
should we should we hear the call yes or
no
please vote no well no here here what
I'll do Dan I'll put it to my ear so
they can't hear him but they can hear me
that's still gonna get picked up on the
mic no no I'll make sure he I'll make
sure that they can't hear him how can
you make sure and then if you can hear
then I'll turn the the volume down this
makes no sense how does it not make
sense it makes perfect because it
literally can still hear okay it's so
close to the mic it's gonna be picked up
no put the microphone away a little bit
Yeah like this yeah it won't hear it all
right
sure
I mean you know what I mean
I got it four it's not even four yeah
can you call now are you calling right
now no I'm I just entered the chat
because last time it was five minutes
early it's a zoom call
no it's via the stir it's a via the
their website oh it's secured that's why
I'm broadcasting at 66 000 people it's
secure don't worry it's a secure line
what are you doing Ethan come on dude
what do you want from me dude this this
is this is my life yeah it's your life
exactly and my life oh
oh no that's my alarm okay you have your
alarms I'm muted too
no no no
I had a
okay it's starting it's starting just
put the mic away
hi doctor how are you a speaker
he's playing games on his phone
icology and we did a ton of uh
additional blood tests
I saw the Radiology
that was all normal
hmm
well I don't hear I don't hear the voice
right
all right no I can't hear anything Ethan
pulled it way down
any body language experts in the
audience
all right Ethan Klein this is your life
oh some coloring books oh nice very nice
hey can you show us a little bit more of
that shirt Ian
let's see it
beautiful is there any cats that are
near and dear to your heart on that
shirt
you wrote your own name in the this book
belongs to
in case it gets lost
Ian's been
using colored pencils in this uh
coloring book recently look at this look
how nice that is
amazing
it's beautiful
now
uh sure what kind of pie is it again
pecan Pekin pecan
I'll have some people oh no Panda going
to kill me I thought you were mad
because I didn't want to eat it for
breakfast this morning though no I was
mad
I'm mad until you try it we'll bring it
up
let's go I've been slamming some salsa
some chippies and salsa um
loves eating vegetables now
Salsa Salsa is vegetables
is the Corn Chip technically a vegetable
too corn is a vegetable yes yeah but
it's not always veggies right there
I love it vegetables is corn a
vegetables that's the thing is it's like
is cool it's all kind of ambiguous isn't
it
fresh corn is a vegetable okay
I knew it
and it's okay but if you continue to
mature and wait for it to harvest until
it's dry then it's considered a grain
that's [__] [__] so you're eating
your grains and vegetables that's what I
was wondering is if it counted as a
grain because it's sort of a staple once
it loses its water it's wheat or rice or
something do you want to see um some
Sketchbook Pages yeah coloring book
it kind of looks like that could be a
coloring book to tell you the truth
someday maybe oh wow I'm doing my own
coloring on it it's really sweet whoops
I just knocked over my flowers wait can
I see the bat which bat in the bottom
right
bottom right hold on oh that's like this
guy oh he's a little cutie
I like
drawn pictures in my picture book
cam have you tried Baldur's Gate yet I'm
gonna get on it okay I'm gonna get on it
soon here's another page
one of the best parts of the game maybe
my favorite part of the entire game is
that uh there's a magic spell to be able
to speak to animals and they fully
voiced every animal in the game if you
choose to like cast a spell and go talk
to it what so there's a voice actor for
every animal that's sick yep
cats I talked I met a pig last night
when I was playing he was what'd the pig
have to say he was very proud of himself
because he was like the prize Pig of the
fair he's a big boy and he was
on top of the world nice it was very
cute pride comes before the fall and
then he turned into bacon right
don't say that
wait I just want to thank everyone for
coming on the soda bar means a lot
whoever was there it was a good time
great show and uh too many many more
are you gonna do anything uh out of
state Zach I don't know thank you that
was such a heavy sigh oh my God nah do
you have your next show planned yet I do
not okay well I do not I wait with
baited breath yeah
why such a heavy sigh on the out of
state thing what about like Vegas or
something that's kind of in the talks
okay or something but okay no uh
[Music]
[__] I might have to come out for that
one yeah I'll probably be really fun
uh extravagant uh
Zach's Vegas weekend the Lost weekend
the last weekend mm-hmm
um there was another Super Chat I wanted
to make sure thank you Sam
look at this that pie is delicious oh my
God it looks so good
look at this all right before I forget
because it was a big donut let's see
what was it uh after I was a trip it was
50 euros from Vasco saying first time
donating to the show here's 50 euros for
Lego lose Lego fun oh thank you thank
you I'm done oh okay
jeez how'd it go
so
so that was the the hematologist
and um
we're just gonna we're just gonna go
back and test my blood in a few months
because
right now things are
it's just hard to know he but I'm
talking to my rheumatologist next week
it's more in his domain he thinks it's
autoimmune thing happening
because my annotider is like a strong
positive
so I've heard and he thinks it's causing
some kind of mild inflammation in my
blood
so
so next week I'll do a live call with my
rheumatologist
great did so could could they hear
anything or no I muted here Mike yeah
after uh the first like well once I
realized that I was looking at a video
of him and that I was gonna have to do
it on speaker yeah oh this isn't gonna
work I got you I got it bro
alfredo okay well no not that many
people left only like 200 so that's fine
okay we're in the home stretch we're
almost done we're in the home stretch so
um but mostly yeah not not nothing uh
nothing to report back really okay well
that's good
congrats no news is good news I have
something to report back this pie is
[__] where'd that python bro I'm so
excited okay do you like it where did
you get that pie let's go damn give it
to me and Sam did you bring enough for
the class would you like a piece of pie
what kind of pie is it pecan the best
yes I want pecan pie dog
one of the best pies I've ever had yeah
really good is there toothpaste in it or
anything
not this time
uh he was considering ordering a bone
marrow biopsy which would be scary oh
that would be horrific but he says he
doesn't think we need it right now they
stick the needle yes yeah and it's the
text for cancer
for blood cancer
but he says he doesn't think we need to
do it right now okay that's good
because if he thought I needed a bone
marrow biopsy that's a bad Vibe yeah and
he would have called for it he would
have well yeah he said I don't assume so
so we're good on that front
someone says I'm about to float towards
the pie
all right let's get we need some pie uh
for this to finish this off oh man all
right so where were we so uh if you go
to the next slide uh swoop
the next one
okay swoop tries to clarify three
different times to get a very clear
answer from Johnny of how he believes he
was groomed by Joshua Evans so be
specific she's saying tell us more yes
she's and then she's like can I have a
smaller sound bite please tell me
okay this is interesting
here's the truth we got over an hour and
a half into our conversation and Johnny
hadn't made any concrete allegations
against Joshua David Evans except that
he was a pret and Sinister I was trying
to give him time while also needing a
more solid answer to work with if my
team was going to invest I'll be honest
I had when I was talking to him I had
the same feeling but I didn't feel like
it would be appropriate for me to be
like how were you groomed it wouldn't
have been right yeah
not in that context yeah this she had
six hours she had she had okay okay you
were on a live show that that totally
makes sense to me right
instigate on his behalf now full
transparency I had to ask Johnny
respectfully at least three times in the
six hour interview Jennifer says I have
cancer right now and it sucks
I can imagine I mean well I can't
imagine well well Jennifer you might not
have to imagine get in there Jennifer
[__] that cancer in the ass oh yeah for
real oh another thing related we paid
off the medical bills right
we did speaking of which because last
time I was talking to my doctor I said I
was going to pay off one person's
medical bills we chose three people that
emailed us
well a lot more than three people
emailed us but of the people emailed it
we paid three just say their names so
that because I don't want
to uh no let's their first name oh just
so they can know that to check I don't
know just a first name
one second
um but yes three of you we did
um I guess send money to cover it so
thank you guys Julia
Daisy and Desiree or the three thank you
my friends
uh thank you guys and uh everybody else
I'm
I uh
I am so sorry and if we can get Sam's
Jeep fun going
um I was watching I saw that clip come
up on my feed
of when we were we were raising money
for Sam's Jeep and we were talking about
how kids with cancer can't pay their
bills it's pretty funny
so I was saying I'm so sorry I couldn't
pay all your bills but the good news is
we did raise
like twenty thousand dollars for Sam's
Jeep
[Music]
really should I button it no go on
whatever
well you know I'm just trying to make a
joke I mean [__] I can't pay everybody
before
sir yeah yeah I'm just trying to make a
joke I wish I could pay all your guys's
bills I do
all right swoops swoopster swoopster uh
where were we
if he would explain exactly I'm in my Mr
Beast era guys
I just for I need to make a video about
it though
I sent a camera to everybody's house
that I paid off their medical bills
they didn't care about the medical so I
bought them a jet ski
thank you Sam this looks amazing are you
freaking kidding me oh my God
the freaking pie
holy [__] it's good it's so good oh my
God she heated it up wow yeah they
really put it over the top
that's the best museum
all right let's watch
quickly if you would please just explain
exactly how he was allegedly groomed by
Joshua David Evans I don't like having
to ask anyone this and I even asked
Johnny multiple times if I had his
consent to ask these tough questions the
questions may not always feel
comfortable
um and just know that I am not here to
make you feel overwhelmed in any way if
you need to take a break uh or if
there's something that you're like you
know what I'm just I'm done with that
question move on
um just just let me know and I will move
kind of according to you I would like to
begin to shift into Joshua Evans his
first answer went on a 10-minute tangent
that ventured into Trent Colleen and
Corey two of whom Johnny directly told
me did not groom him so I asked Johnny
to explain for a quicker sound bite you
have obviously said that you believe
that Josh groomed you yes can you just
give me a summary of exactly what Josh
did that has
made you feel that way Josh has an ego a
massive one and it's one that I can
pinpoint and address not even knowing
the dude on a personal level to this day
he took the power that he had over me
and
it turned into this God complex where I
think to this day he has this skewed
idea that he was being a mentor he was a
dude pushing 30. boo leeched on to a
vulnerable kid when he was in town he
did the Harlem Shake video we filmed a
little goofy stupid video for my channel
there was a contest he did once there
were like maybe eight of us who
submitted videos I won
and my prize was a ball of duct tape
it's just the
how's that grooming because you didn't
get a dope prize
one time he didn't give me a dope prize
he didn't give me that duct tape off
wow little things if you look at them
and see the patterns so to recap
Johnny's answer he could have said
it was the that he you know
was using me to do stuff like the
Twitter
that's probably the only valid one that
I know of he could have said but I'm
sure he didn't even think about it yeah
as to exactly how Joshua allegedly
groomed him he said Josh has an ego a
God complex he thought he was a mentor
he was pushing 30 and leeched they
created an original trending Harlem
Shake content at the auto show his whole
family showed up at and that Johnny
entered a contest for a ball of duct
tape and one a ball of duct tape that he
still has I gently
also when you look at like the
conversation around the auto show
Josh was like so not inviting
he was so short with his answers yeah
he asked him multiple times and tried to
get a concise answer here's what he said
and I will sprinkle in the additional
context that was left out again if you
could if you I'm sorry for asking a
second time but just I just want to kind
of nail down exactly specifically what
you think were the kind of the exact
things that Josh did that leave you
feeling like you were groomed yeah so
first and foremost giving a 16 year old
your phone number I'm provoke full
context that we know Johnny had
mentioned to Josh that he was depressed
around this time Joshua said he would
Mentor Johnny and Josh gave his phone
number in front of Johnny's parents
while Johnny was networking Johnny
showed the number to his parents and
they were excited that maybe he was
getting his big break they literally
said our kids doing the damn thing our
kid is doing the damn thing he continues
hanging out with the person one-on-one
the instances they hung out were always
in public and most so did they ever hang
out one-on-one
so he says to swoop that they hung out
one-on-one at a Starbucks at the audio
came out right at the auto show which
was
it was inside of the center in the
Starbucks surrounded by people and his
parents weren't with them at the
Starbucks but they were at the event and
that's where he came out to him no no
that's the that's the auto show that's
when he says that they hung out alone
okay because it said it sounds like the
time he came out to him alone
right
you know what let me I want to triple
check on that
this sucks because like you never want
to have to question people like this I
know
but I was in public both times were in
public
yeah in public spots I mean
it can still be grooming even though
it's like in public private whatever
just to be specific I feel like
all right because it's not he mentioned
it's grooming but not sexual which sure
grooming can be non-sexual right right
yeah I'm not saying it can't be groomed
no I know I know just trying I'm just
trying to um
get the details straight because how old
was he when he was alone with him
15. at the auto show I think
their first time but I need to make sure
of that
when he came out to him in La he was 19.
oh okay well that's yeah
I mean just based on the messages we saw
yeah for sure I don't know
it seems like a stretch and it sucks
because yeah it's weird you never want
to you never want to question it
I feel so bad that to question it right
right
often when Johnny's family members were
with him and the remaining time when
Johnny was an adult having conversations
about our personal lives getting to know
came on an intimate level
um he came out to Josh at a show in
California at the end of the meet and
greet in public swoop says
okay
fast forwarding to today I feel more
confident to say I was groomed if there
were conversations about their personal
lives on an intimate level Johnny has
not shared these with me or seemingly
anybody if there is more I wasn't able
to get it in the six hour interview this
man repeatedly told all of you who asked
him to explain how he was groomed he
always deflected by tweeting things like
I don't have to explain myself again
listen to swoop well thanks for
listening to what Johnny said in that
instance because hi swoop here I think
this man is full of [__] and a victim
blamer allegedly after Johnny told me
before about how Joshua
yeah we're heading toward the end we're
about to get to the crush Theory and
then his statement and then my
um I have more mementos that I found I
mean just based on what we've seen and
it is possible that we haven't seen
everything
although Johnny certainly has an
interest in Sharing anything that would
support his theory
it's not it's not even close to grooming
it's Stephanie so far it's troubling
compared I mean based on like what he
said before and now this evidence it's
it's definitely
it does not line up
I mean it's inappropriate
it is there was an inappropriate yes
um
boundary
but when it came to actually the
conversations he really does keep him at
arm's length
and keep in mind we saw like
evidence of choline engaging sexually
with minors and after those came to
light he still said what Josh did to him
was possibly worse right the implication
yes as [__] it's so dangerous because
you could just be like yo what's [__]
up what Josh did like he had me doing
his Twitter he gave me he was texting me
it was like yeah that is that's weird
yeah but then to go further with it
like he was on Twitter saying like
he needs to to answer for what he did
which again is weird if you're lying
about stuff yeah right
yeah I think we can say based on what we
saw inappropriate
but not grooming
you know yeah
I think it's important that we make
these distinctions too because I feel
like Guru a word like grooming is losing
its meaning a little bit here
go man he was I I listen
I know definitions can change
I understood grooming as like what
priests do to kids yes it's like the
lead up to essay of children
like it's it's really exciting yeah it's
like really serious it's just uh gave
the definition with the 20 Super Chat
coincidentally just now which is uh
grooming definition grooming refers to
action behavior used to establish an
emotional connection with the minor and
sometimes a child's family to lower the
child's inhibitions with the objective
of essay so
in my the way I understood it at a very
specific
um meaning and that meaning is like
heinous it's it's basically equal to
leading up to actual uh assault of a
child
and so
when the meeting gets this when the word
gets distilled a little bit
I think it's confusing because you're
saying he groomed you
but he would there so but a lot of
people understand the word like I do it
has this really really [__] up
connotation
and you mean he was just trying to like
get you to do his Twitter
because that's not grooming as I
understand it but it's confusing because
it conjures this
feeling of you know the deepest possible
crime you could commit
which is abusing a child lying to a
child and to possibly like water down
the stories of the other victims that
are in this or like potentially washing
out their own experiences with his story
and his proven lies it's it's really
I feel I feel very bad for
or Adam and Oliver and Becky and
everyone's stories who were the yeah the
the they were a real victims yeah and
he's been Johnny has been actively
trying to suppress those like Adam's
story really I'm trying yeah his story
was more important yeah he tried to make
his story more important I feel like
there's two issues here him being kind
of like rude and mean to all these other
victims trying to like stomp them down
and then also uh what's his name uh Adam
no that's not Oliver Joshua Joshua yeah
being kinda inappropriate with this
child yeah like that's a separate not
grooming probably at least to the
standard definition but at the very
least like kind of exploitative of a
show yeah false hope making him work for
free it's kind of weird yeah giving his
phone number is very weird like there's
a lot of it's inappropriate and
inappropriate with a relationship with a
child already sounds bad yeah yeah
exactly yeah the grooming exactly is
necessary yeah and so but right there's
I feel like there's two issues here him
kind of yeah
yeah but so are we should we as
you know people online or people uh this
generation who talk about it
should we open the word grooming
to mean all this different stuff or
should we you know
try to be more specific because it's way
too broad and I think it it's
especially an environment where on the
flip side of all of this uh it is also a
term that is frequently thrown around to
in reference to like teachers that are
lgbtq friendly right and uh trans
activists and all this like we we're in
an environment where that the meaning of
that is already being deluded for
nefarious purposes constantly and we
don't need you know more stuff piling on
and just kind of muddying the waters
what we're really talking about here
right well they use it in the worst
sense of the word they do think that you
know they're trying to [__] the kids
right right
so
yeah I don't know I I think I think it'd
be it'd be useful to be careful with how
we use the word grooming but I know
language tends to you know change and
that's just what it is sometimes
you know that is true grooming also
means you know to cut your beard what
are you gonna do about that
I'm going to go to manscape.com and use
code H3 there it is
manscape.com H3 grooming
no good no I mean it's literal I'm just
being literal
get groomed dad that's
no good no okay if you wanna
move
so are we here we're moving forward I
decided so give Johnny another moment
we're moving to the crush Theory this is
the
the time stamp that the Reddit thinks is
most pertinent when it comes to that
right here uh if you did you click on
the crush theory link let me go to the
PowerPoint presentation
to the crush theory is it the next slide
yeah
the crush Theory okay this is that that
Johnny is romantically
uh romantic feelings for Josh
okay interesting
at all but as Johnny has referenced his
coming out story multiple times across
countless media platforms and attached
it to accusations it would be
irresponsible of me to not at least
mention it here in reality I was deeply
troubled by the thought that Joshua
could have discouraged him or anyone for
coming out so we had to investigate I
agree that was really a weird moment
when he talked about his reaction so
it's good to look a little deeper into
that why Josh may have allegedly
responded that way when he was
indicating the to not talk to your
parents did he explain why he felt that
way he was alluding that they were gonna
kick me out and disown me for being gay
because I grew up in a very Catholic
conservative household Loosely it's like
traditional if you will do you think
that he was trying to say it in a
protective way like I don't want you to
get hurt by your parents I don't know he
knew my parents so like just insulted on
their behalf as well if it was a
situation where he was like I don't know
how to handle this if he thought I had
some crush on him well to assume I'm so
confused by he says he knew his parents
but based on what we've said they've
they've sent like 20 DMS he barely knows
him well his parents went with him to
his show
like they didn't talk about his family
once in the messages we saw yeah
well no more after the interview drops
[Music]
talk to him yeah assume you're
attractive enough for me to have a crush
on you Mr David hold on assume you're
attractive I don't know how to handle
this if he thought I had some crush on
him well to assumed you're attractive
enough for me to have a crush on you Mr
David Evans where did that come from
his internal monologue I don't because
he never mentioned that originally no
so he says he keeps going okay and
that's not even like bagging on him for
his looks he's clearly an attractive
dude oh
[Music]
is that enough to say O2 yeah
do I need to button that out no
oh he mean he's a 27 year old
but the personality is what does it for
me and he ain't got one that I'm
attracted to you sure
[Music]
now I asked Joshua about his side of the
coming out yesterday when he was 19.
but
yeah yeah yeah we're good yeah fair
thing to do here which I will share with
you later but for right now out of
respect I'm going to let this story
live where it is so we'll move on let's
back up first that's just
that's a potential Theory that's living
on the Reddit so I felt that personally
from what I've seen
there's almost no other explanation
at least like there was some romantic
feelings on on
um so pretty it could it could just
purely be
like a a
die-hard fandom thing
I I I I kind of lean that way as well
but just to be fair like we haven't
really
though it doesn't seem like you just
wanted to get close to him he did that
right because he worked for her yeah he
did he did I don't remember how that
came to be
he said that after the divorce he kind
of well he sided with Colleen because
Josh stop
ped engaging
which is the right thing to do by the
way and he was also struggling like
immensely he quit like three days after
they announced their divorce I'm sure he
wasn't thinking about Johnny it's a
weird thing to say he stopped trying to
groom me as a bad thing right
um so not long after swoop uh released
this Johnny put out a note statement on
Twitter Johnny said on Twitter betrayed
is an understatement my trauma was used
against me today in a way I never
imagined what happened I was given
guidance and a safe space to share my
story I was praised for being so
vulnerable and honest only to be defamed
on such a gross level
it feels Beyond explanation right now
feels so hurt and disregarded swoop you
claim to stand for victims and what you
did today is the polar opposite you have
no regard for my life the trauma I faced
my safety or the safety of so many
others involved
and you've completely shifted The
Narrative while making sure to promote
your merch
and fabricate a story for some extra
Revenue
I'm so beyond disgusted by all this I'm
not going to sit here and defend myself
to every one of your heinous allegations
about me via Notes app but I will be
making a proper statement regarding all
of these disgusting and false statements
this is 100 character assassination I
won't stand for it swoop you encouraged
me and made me feel like you were a
massive source of trust you chose to
interview Adam about allegations
regarding me rather than talking to me
about it which is scummy you wanted
information at your request as if I
wasn't working full-time
in the process of moving which I was
upfront about you can call names and
spread your lies but I know my truth and
I will not stop sharing it because of
people like you
okay
so I mean how do we feel
well
he's a consistent he's being consistent
yeah that's what if if
I'm Johnny
and either I believe what I said is true
or I'm just going with that
then this statement is basically you
know exactly what I would expect
what did you expect
it's not an expectation I mean he he
doctored the [__] text messages this
case closed at that point yeah like
you're a liar you're manipulating the
situation
there should like if that if he really
did that which I have no reason to like
that would be pretty wild if swoop just
made all that up yeah but I mean that's
the slam dunk that you're full of [__]
dude like you you edited the
conversation to try and make it look
worse than it was
but I think the the the the huge
defensiveness instead of being like
there were some points here that I'd
like to clarify in a future statement
but like the but it's a hundred percent
lies so it's like did swoop just make
that all up
just fabricated that entire thing about
like the messages not matching up I
guess Johnny wants us to think so
I mean that's pretty [__] crazy I
yeah I don't know I don't know swoop
that well but I I don't know I swoop
would never I don't think swoop would do
that
swoop would never lead us astray no
ever I mean it's GG at that point like
what else is there even the sayings it's
very uh it's just like flatly deny it
it's a hundred percent untrue it's like
okay dude
I am curious about his uh
statement whatever he's planning but um
it's not looking good for Johnny
so coming up swoops next doc is an
exclusive interview with Joshua Evans
alrighty
is crazy
yo this [__] is drama I've been looking
pretty intense I have needed I have
literally like wondered what happened
for years it's it's literally it's so
cool is he gonna spill all yeah it's
well watch the one thing that she
includes in the trailer of course he's
gonna spill everything
let's go literally so insane take one
my name is Joshua David Evans I'm 39.
Joshua we have a lot to talk about in
person so where does he live where does
she live did they travel
um I actually don't know where swoop
lives or where she's based I'm assuming
someone had to travel for this probably
him because they're all set up yeah
obviously there are allegations that
have been levied against you and we're
going to get into those but you have
also alleged that you are a victim as
well a victim of abuse and that's the
production value pretty good wonderful I
know it's like a dateline thing pretty
slick yeah
I was thinking um although it's swoop
just a piece of friendly advice at the
beginning with when you're doing the
dramatic like we're gonna slate this
thing like you got to get a clapboard
the the hand clap thing not as good
that's not that's not front line also it
would look it would tie it all together
if there was a Clapper right there
should we send her a Clapper and good
maybe as a friend thank you
should we get you a Clapper a nice a
nice Clapper
we'll work on that we'll work on that
okay Sam are you here
I'm here she's here can we do you think
we can make like a bedazzled swoop there
it is Clapper of course that'd be fun
right yeah it would be fun I'm down nice
yeah nice
um the I I genuinely gaslighting is
another term that I think is
way overused it has a very specific
meaning I feel that Johnny
if what we're seeing is all true
was gaslighting Josh
into thinking that Josh
really traumatizes
when he was telling his story he
literally well he got Josh to apologize
for basically nothing yeah well that's
not true he did [__] up Josh did [__] up
and it seemed like he directly addressed
the the places that we identify were
like he [__] up what are the things
that he was addressing in that apology
all right let's see what let's see this
I don't think that I and my team take
very seriously so I went from the
boyfriend to the fiance that to the
husband to now I started to feel almost
like a character like I was replaceable
she loved the attention she loved
status but do I think she truly loves
her fans I never really felt like she
did I think she just loved what it gave
her she's having a few people over to
the house and I was like who they said
Eric and when I walk through those doors
this part it reeked of alcohol and
cigarettes
and no one was there nobody was there
and then I went upstairs
and she was sitting on our bed
playing her ukulele
but I looked at her
no no
the ukulele God
holy [__] I did not expect him to say
that this line he's about to say it I
had to back up and re-watch it I
couldn't believe it the [__] yep yep
not this
[Laughter]
all right let me and I said when you're
effing Eric in our bed I want you to
think of me but I've lost like
everything are you kidding that's crazy
that's [__] crazy that he said that
that's the first time it's been
absolutely cut and dry Colleen cheated
on Josh in their bed he's saying he said
when you're [__] Eric in our bed he
did say that think about me she's not
thinking about you I think she was she
she had her fans like tear him down on
Twitter for years following wait I'm
confused he said he said to Colleen when
you're [__] Eric who she was cheating
on him with I want you to think about me
yeah I'm saying she wasn't thinking
about him
right she was thinking about Eric's
[__] new strange [__] maybe but she
tried to be uncouth
he was getting some strange debt I
I don't know she actively tormented him
for years after though was that really a
full confirmation in that Olivia I think
you might no no [__] Eric in our bed
yeah like because he he suspected it
based on the smell
and her just sitting there playing uke
okay it wasn't like she I caught her
interesting because that's what I
thought he was leading up to that's why
when he dropped the ukulele line I was I
was shocked he might in the interview
and it certainly sounds like he
suspected it right
but to say it's a full confirmation it's
still not there yeah just to be totally
right I mean I jumped the gun I was too
late for it you've been waiting years
for years did it happen it seems like
waiting for this movie it doesn't seem
like that if you uh I include actually I
found more mementos from my fake
Instagram I like vinsta and I literally
predicted like two days before they got
divorced that they were gonna get
divorced really yeah if you go to the
next slide
bad I want you to think of me I've lost
everything I lost my career I lost
everything that I do Johnny has accused
you of some very serious allegations he
has accused you of grooming him do you
agree with that characterization of you
no
at first it was felt normal and chill to
have like oh that's Johnny he's at the
show I didn't know that that was going
to be
time
time would continuously show up at these
shows he's out there dragging my name
publicly I kind of know what he means
like
if you keep going and you meet a fan and
it's like oh cool nice to meet you you
know you shake hands you learn their
name and stuff but then they're always
there and then all of a sudden like
it's becoming something but I don't know
because he did talk with him on the
phone I can't give him the benefit of
the doubt on that one right I can't he
did engage yeah for the interview she
swoop does say that she grills him about
the stuff that I believe it when does
this come out
this comes out hope I think
maybe
next week next week I don't know
hopefully soon I gotta get that quote
I'm editing I mean I want to watch it
everyone's like poor Johnny I can't
believe Josh just abandoned you and I'm
like
who Do You Think You Are
my life
was wrecked
yes I sat down with Joshua David Evans
okay for seven hours seven [__] hours
yeah John that beats Johnny six
more embarrassing Colleen versus Josh uh
Olivia momentos okay yes so I'm by the
way being very hyperbolic in these
captions this was just to my best
friends but I posted on September 26th
just so everyone knows these are my
heroes I think that they're getting a
divorce so if I'm sad that's why cool
and then
on September 30th I posted just so
everyone knows tonight is going to be a
rough night for me actually I'm not
joking what's up Colleen and Josh are
getting a divorce I'm stopping in a rojo
sushi right now I remember bearing in
the club I was I remember very quick
very clearly I was at aroha Sushi and um
I went to the bathroom because I saw
that she had posted a video or no
someone commented on my previous post
where I said I think that they're
getting a divorce and they're like did
you see her new video and so I ran to
the bathroom watched it started crying
went back to the table was just like I
can't believe this I was right and then
my friends were like oh
why maybe it's because I'm just I'm a
different kind of person but I just got
scared of that [__] pillow dude dude
who's there yeah every time I catch it
out of the corner of my eye I I jump I
was like what though yeah talking about
the one that Howie gave me yeah
yeah um I'm just thinking why did Josh
not defend himself because it seems like
he had
you know a really easy way to defend
himself with the Colleen stuff she
cheated on me with the Johnny stuff
here's the here's our whole conversation
there's nothing there
I just don't maybe just a different kind
of guy than me because you know what I
mean but I don't know
um maybe maybe also it was at the height
of all the Colleen [__] right and
probably like coming out and against an
accuser by the way I'm not right at that
moment would have
I'm not saying that like it's evidence
that he's lying or anything I'm just no
no I'm in from like people handle it
from my perspective of how I would have
handled that I mean with hindsight he'd
he probably shouldn't have posted well I
guess with hindsight it actually is okay
because now the truth is starting to
find its way out
um so Olivia's crying in the club right
here's another one
um this one was during 2020 this is when
Josh started posting videos again once
he got sober and I posted a screenshot
of it and I totally forgot about it I
quoted him life can be good but you've
got to choose it I love you forever Josh
if anyone hasn't kept up he's finally
doing better
crying in the club but and then my
friend commented Colleen is
at this point I was still a fan of
Colleen this is right when Adam first
came out with his story the first time
this is like Rage Comic speak what she
said listening it's like a less snake
it's like French she's a snake basically
and I said I'm having a hard time loving
her still because I think she totally
gas lit Josh's suffering and also I
think she may have cheated with Eric and
now she's publicly has a baby with him
and Josh just went off the deep bed and
my friend said and did you see that
drama with the 16 year old and I said of
course who do you think I am I'm so mad
Colleen hasn't responded pretending it
isn't happening just seems so fake like
what is she just what is she what else
is she lying about not telling us
hashtag I'm going off
I remember that
see I had the suspicion forever you were
right the whole time yeah just as you
are now you knew this is a secret I kept
from everybody
I met Colleen Ballinger one time
okay go on so my math teacher in high
school knew that I really liked her and
her husband just so happened to be a
writer on her Netflix show like he was
just one of the like writing assistants
or something and so she invited me to
the premiere to be her plus one date I
didn't take a photo with Colleen I was
too freaked out but I I had my friend
take a picture of uh my feet before I
like told her hi my name is Olivia
sounds like you were groomed by your
teacher yeah so that was when I met her
that's a photo I have can you read this
sure my feet
my Hero's feet Colleen Ballinger stood
next to her by the way this is not
serious I hope you all know accidentally
told her sister Rachel her cousin's name
don't worry about it which means that
this is serious what do you mean it's
serious and that I was yeah but not that
I was like not that I was like ill
I mean I was happy to meet her okay
um but this was just supposed to be to
like my best friends who knew I loved
her accidentally told her sister her
cousin her uh cousin's name don't worry
about it I told Colleen she meant the
world to me she said I was beautiful uh
when she left I stood there how do you
decide what to say to somebody you know
so well but doesn't know you at all and
then I said I'm full of happiness
and that's where the story ends thank
you have you ever met have you ever met
a celebrity you like
I feel like that's where you came your
feet together
my friend took that marfied because I
felt I felt too disrespectful at her
like own event being like can I please
can I please take a photo with you and
she was super busy so I was just like
whatever yo but she's a groomer so
swoopy's on here with the 2021 winner
oh streamy Awards Creator honor what
does that mean
it means she's honorable
well I'm about going you're not the only
one
swoopy doopy I'm gonna have to get my my
my Olive branches uh Laurels we'll see
mm-hmm
we'll see you guys have guilted me into
going to this [__] event
yeah have we talked have we announced
that did we talk about it on Friday I
think we did
we're going to the streamies people
in person and I'm not talking about
Bizarro Ethan I'm talking about the real
[__] deal this man dragged his feet
for weeks but thankfully Ela wears the
pants in the relationship and she wanted
to go down even
been with Ela which rarely do you push
back on Ela but she really want to go
and you were like bro I'm not doing this
okay it wasn't the ELA thing it was the
fact that not one of you [__]
would agree and say it's dumb you all
wanted to go we all think I mean I won't
speak for everybody I do think it's dumb
but I think it will be a lot of fun and
we will get some great uh stories and
content out of it
they announced the the award during the
commercial I'm not talking about that
I'm talking about it you gotta go to
these events we're gonna run into some
of the people that we talk about on the
show you might have you guys got it back
you've been telling the Logan Paul story
over and over again for like six years
you need a new Logan Paul story
or some other Creator threatening to
hurt you physically
because you got to back me up in case if
it goes down and you know we're jumping
in really yeah of course yeah that'd be
awesome
H Street podcast got into a brawl at the
streaming all of us like could we fight
yeah
potentially If Logan if he was there
he's a petty little [__]
Logan
he's big though I might take it back
about the jumping in come on bro that
dude is [__] yoked well yeah but he
can't take us all
and Mike might switch allegiances if
Mike's with him he might jump though
Benedict Arnold yeah uh he's too he's
too much
he couldn't he couldn't bring himself
you're right he would just hold Logan
back yeah he cares too much about us
yeah
okay well we're going that's it
we're going
well also we made all these silly
so I almost had an out because we
discovered we had a vacation planned on
that weekend yeah and it cost us a lot
of money
to reschedule it to a more expensive day
and so I almost had an out
but the thing that made me be like all
right let's just do it because we had
talked to the streamies and gave them
all the silly stuff like every crew
member and their significant others and
we need a table at the front and then I
would have felt like such an [__] if
we canceled after all that [__] and they
were really listen I'll be I'll be real
they were very accommodated to us very
accommodating
because I think we're gonna win this
year
we're all gonna do the red carpet you
guys yeah we're gonna do their whole red
carpet thing we're gonna dress up
um I don't
and I'm not just saying this to manage
expectations I don't think that we're
going to win dude but I still think
we're gonna have a lot of fun and I
think it will be funny when we don't win
and then we get all I'm never going back
if I do win then I'm gonna say actually
I'll save it Shetty has this in the bag
dude I think they're gonna give us
podcasts of the year and then Jay
shetty's gonna win creator of the year
because I agree cam if they give Shetty
both it's like what are we doing here
this is just the shitty Awards
well and it's not just shitty you didn't
uh
uh call her daddy win last year or
something and they're nominated again
too so the worst neighbors would be
impulsive that would be the biggest kick
in the teeth
more than Shetty yeah because he's just
saying yeah frankly yeah that wouldn't
be worth it yeah
the dude is trash yeah like I'll
probably if Shetty wins over us I'll
probably laugh if impulsive one I'd
probably be kind of mad yes exactly he's
up for a creator of the year and also
Creator product of the year with Prime
yeah for what for dink dunk
yeah a couple years ago now but the yeah
well he did the crypto Zoo this year
that's another scam he did this year
sure and he hasn't paid anyone back for
it he said he's going to pay back 1.7
million he hasn't done that at all right
uh Ethan I've been keeping up with below
deck I just started watching it I love
the Australian one
I love that [__] but I only watched one
episode but that's my favorite
I love the Aussies
um
well well
that was a big one uh it took us that
was there was a lot to go for I thought
it was going to be way shorter than that
me too
but I do want to say
there's obviously a lot of context
a lot more information that you guys
should consume over on swoop D dupees
Channel yes I linked the video in the
description swoop there it is come on
come on swoop there it is thank you
swoop for all of the tireless work you
put in it's really it was like
outstanding it was crazy and um I guess
Josh never got back to us Josh did send
me a DM he's unable to call in today
I'll tell you I'll talk to you okay
we said uh you all are sleeping on the
yard podcast they're your biggest
competition probably yeah
Ludwig's thing
and they have a slide
let me show everyone let me just check
the yard oh I know views aren't
everything okay but let's just check the
views
sorry
get him
just saying
yeah they're not hitting that hard I'm
not not here to flex
but
it's not all about views no that's what
I said I mean he was shitty he probably
has this licked I don't say that no
no [__] what's a [__] I make like a
sliding scale he's pretty inconsistent
with his vehicle what does Shaq get on
Facebook because that's where he shines
and like I think people listen to like
the audio version of his podcast a lot
yeah shitty Facebook on YouTube
audio version
let's check the shed views on on YouTube
yeah dude where's the views at 40 000.
this evening is part this isn't his
podcast this is a main ass Channel
with five million subscribers this man
put out a video they got 40 000 views
two months ago wow Jesus
that's his daughter man show
I forgot about it last episode two
months ago 100 000 views what the [__]
bro that's not his main and by the way
this is still not the talk about like
accomplishments these people do one
episode a week we are out here doing
five episodes a week for better or worse
baby four [__] hours better or worse
nobody does that
it's time to acknowledge that here's his
actual podcast uh you got it oh what the
[__] you gotta watch no wonder that one
all right you gotta watch the Joe Biden
intro
at the top right why did Joe Biden yeah
I only pulled 300. let's see on purpose
health and wellness wow okay Jay
shetty's podcast on purpose is the
number one Health and Wellness podcast
that's AI the president participated in
an interview with uh Jimmy who you all
know to discuss the administration the
Mental Health crisis
nobody's watching
it's got okay views where are you at
Shady heads oh yeah an interview an
interview on YouTube with President
United States only getting 300K views is
kind of sad well his normal ones like
Bryce Hall got 75 000. a rack got
nobody cares about a nobody cares about
Iraq that dude's ugly but where'd he go
they haven't done episode two months
even I'm only saying that because he
called Ethan ugly
that's what's going for context yo this
man hasn't even made a podcast in two
months
um are you even gonna put him in the
category with me um does it hold a
handle to me
you're looking at darman's side Channel
well I'm trying to find their [__]
no he does a week
yeah
here's [__] okay here's the J Shetty
podcast
this is what I was looking at
that's I had that one up
oh okay
so let's see oh yeah Joey Boy
this one is third okay whatever
we want more people watching live right
now
oh Jesus right again views aren't any
anything everything but it's something
yeah that's I mean that is a good point
but why does everybody know who he is
they don't because of you
at the award show it's like Jay Shetty a
lot of people machete Joe Biden people
love Jay Shetty we have a we have ice
fishing stand in the building right now
Kendall Jenner
Joe [__] Biden Tom Holland Kim
Kardashian why is this happening
Tom Ward is his book Selena Gomez
I know I watched that one wow I'm sorry
I watched that one Matthew McConaughey
Kevin Hart
I mean he probably just glazes them up
yeah for sure it's like easy PR
oud tell me
um Matthew tell me about this really
exciting new lifestyle thing you're
promoting it sounds so interesting
I call it what's it called
it's green lights baby
if you sign up for green lights at 1999.
oh is this McConaughey that you're doing
yeah oh it's pretty good five percent
more trust I didn't know it was five
percent more trips five
all I need is five percent more trucks
more trustworthy if you own it that you
do have the courage to trust do you have
the courage to trust five percent what
the [__] are you talking about
I'm gonna care five percent more
precisely
a lot of shitty fans in the chat okay
come on
you gotta choose it's me or him his eyes
are perfect yeah with eyes like those
this town is not big enough for the two
I've never seen such gorgeous hazel eyes
that's all he has been without his eyes
he's nobody
if I had Hazels like him forget it I
would have won I tried to help you with
that but you refused to put in the
colored uh contacts ones oh there's too
much of it they still have them yeah we
still have them we were gonna do a gag
where he he got shitty eyes
like everyone's like oh Ethan's
connected I never even got Susan
wojinski to come on my show I tried she
didn't want to come on she wants to talk
to Jay Shetty
for twenty thirty seven thousand years
where's all the exposed videos on him
for me
[Music]
thank you
that's funny
anyway I found a baby photo of Jay he
has blue eyes stunning blue eyes
I mean he posted it yeah all right we'll
stay with us blue eyes yeah I mean I
thought his eyes were Hazel
if we don't win this year I just I can't
do this anymore with the streamies nah
[__] this is it it's all about them I
agree I can't do this I'm not saying we
should go every year but like come on
it's going to be an experience to do the
race it's not had Matt Damon on his
podcast and got 14 000 views this is
straight up Tom Tom Wards gets better
views in this book oh that's true shout
out to him
how the [__] yeah dude 11 years ago we
were in Haiti yeah nobody's watching and
this is one of those episodes where is
the funding didn't you like hold on 400
likes did he re-upload it or something
because one year ago crazy how does how
the [__] is Jay Shetty not getting more
views on a Matt Damon well it's
consistent with all this [__]
[Music]
maybe a YouTube you know maybe it's just
not a YouTube is he trending on the
iTunes chart what's his Facebook views
do we get any info on that Facebook Jake
and what is it on purpose oh you got an
interview with Tony Robbins
how to brainwash yourself for success
I had a tumor in my brain when I was 11
years old and I grew Mega tall I like to
use my my height
and forced to intimidate women he has
less followers on Facebook than he does
on YouTube what
I thought he was all on Facebook 780k
followers Sam what is happening no no he
has 25 million on his main okay so this
is just his podcast page yeah on Spotify
Spotify and that's what I was saying is
I think people actually listen to his as
an audio podcast you know what I mean I
actually didn't even know there was a
video uh component told us now okay 29
million followers on Facebook wow so his
podcast about charting
Sam you think I would like it should I
listen I think it's a good podcast I
mean I don't know if you like health and
wellness and I could learn a lot yeah I
think that it's a good podcast I will
say ours is definitely and by the way
it used to be a monk artist yeah
opinions expressed by people on this
show do not represent our organization
as a whole just to make that clear well
I was gonna say our show is definitely
way more effort more involved better
produced everything let's go like you
said I mean you made a good point we are
year five days a week that's gotta be
worth something nobody does that
you know
I'm sick of groveling to the streamings
please recognize me
please no I made the Streamys I am the
Streamys so he's a Hare Krishna yeah
oh fascinating
man don't you start I think I I think I
like this Jay Shetty [__] Hari
Krishna
stop
all right I'm a Hari Krishna Mahari
these nuts between your butt cheeks
thanks love wow
wow not impressed
and if it's not obvious I'm obviously
being hyperbolic about everything I'm
saying right now before there's like a
Ethan's actually vein and
we know you're just jealous it's okay
yeah I'm jealous Court who wouldn't be
jealous of Jay Shetty
yeah I'm [__] jealous
Joseph's eyes Joseph is guests Joseph
his Awards
no so looking at his Facebook his
biggest juicers are like all
um or no what's his name Dharma and
content it's so weird he didn't blow up
doing body cast he blew up doing this
Darman contest right he already had kind
of like a what is he talking what does
he do with Darman dude he he's like
super busy no he's doing his own
dharmon type content oh yeah that's how
we blow up oh can I watch one of those
well I don't know it's getting so late
I'm a [__] psycho If I Stay yeah
let's let me open I have to look real
fast I gotta know who I'm up against
if I win would it be inappropriate to
say oh and by the way up yours Jay
Shetty
would it be inappropriate yeah yeah I
mean I guess but oh and by the way up
here's Jay Shetty
I feel like because he's so like kind of
universally liked and like clean image
it's like actually pretty [__] funny
yeah
it's like saying up here still like uh
Dolly Parton or something yeah exactly
somebody who's like universally liked
let's see what the [__] this is
he doesn't come in until the end would
you mind if we took a photo together I'm
just I'm such a huge fan oh it's exactly
the same yeah
boyfriend abandons disabled girlfriend
Watch What Happens Next same title
but when it comes to significant life
changes I challenge you I'm sorry but
nobody's learning from this [__]
disabled this is [__]
hey guys listen don't leave your girl
your boyfriend when he gets cancer love
comes in all different forms yeah I can
do that too
listen if you're if your boyfriend
stay by their side it's the right thing
to do
you wouldn't like it if somebody
abandoned you and you got cancer
look into my eyes [__]
you know what I'm saying is true
look and keep my deep Hazels
[Music]
yeah these are for you
I am looking for the dumb Cancer girl
[Music]
I heard about your accident I hope
you're recovering okay you are such an
amazing soccer player
and my role model
this hasn't changed that fact
[Music]
bro get on with it
my God
people are crying right now
[Music]
play Chestnut Zack when you're coping
with a big stoppage
I know it's so [__] weird why is he
on the left well this is like a
Ridiculousness [__] dude he has a giant
laptop stay uh set it's bizarre because
it's it's in a vertical content and then
he is on a uh horizontal in a vertical
it's like super tiny it just means
having his cake and eating it too why is
he not on a phone that would make more
sense they could actually it's really
funny because they're lazy they just
want to do it on Tick Tock they want to
do it on YouTube let me hear what he has
to say it is let me hear this Hare
Krishna [__]
video illness or big relationship coming
to a close it may feel like part of your
world is there you go
um
this is in a sense true after a big
change means that an aspect of your life
has been altered but when it comes to
significant life changes I challenge you
to look at this as not something
absolute that means that your life is
over but rather that one chapter of your
life is over and a new one is beginning
but how do you get to this place after
all any major his hair is oh manicure
he's kind of cooking
okay fine but look how vain he is I'm
telling you that hair it looks unkempt
no no no no
do you know how much effort it takes to
look unkempt you just roll out of bed
and he just looks like 100 he's just
that hot now they do this [__] oh yeah
yeah and it's this and it's this yeah
and it's this it is I know that for a
fact Ian let me see it on screen again
he might even have straight hair and
he's got to do like a perm and [__] yeah
because it's that dry [__] in there too
you can see it's kind of dry there's
different levels yeah there's doing your
hair
and then there's doing your hair so it
looks like you don't care she's shitty a
hairline King
I don't know he's got to come forward a
little bit James Charles always does
that
um
I guess we just don't know he doesn't
want people to know he's vain because he
does his hair up but he's very vain
I don't know he is he's got a little bit
of a beard five o'clock shadow perfectly
rolled out of bed I think he just looks
that good you need to not care about
your hygiene like me
you gotta not worry about having a
capped hair and beard that's how you
prove that you really don't care
like me
the change is likely to bring about big
emotions and getting to a spot in which
you're at peace with this event may seem
a long way however there are several
steps you can take to help facilitate
this process and cope with the change
allow yourself how old is she I feel
like you're not old enough to be giving
us like wisdom
how old are you Jason you're giving me
wisdom he is uh 35.
you guys can take wisdom from me I'm
three years older than him 35 is not old
enough to give voice dumb it's not you
can't you've been doing this show for
six years I'm not giving wisdom I'm
talking the opposite frankly
you know okay fair enough here's the
thing you can't get Nirvana by 35.
he's Hari Krishna I don't know what that
means what does Hari Krishna mean
no one knows uh he was a former monk in
the international Society for Krishna
you know why former because he got
kicked out
he got banned he's on Facebook all the
time
yep exactly it's a type of uh Hindu
religion
what does it mean though
it's a denomination of it's like a
denomination yeah so it should but
what's cool it's like why is it
seems like cool
the Hare Krishna it seems like dope I
don't know where you're getting that
from well you said you you loved that
he's a Hare Krishna I was trying to rile
you up
success you got what you wish for Dad
well the Beatles song don't they uh yeah
um
became very uh uh involved that's my
movement that's why I'm still right
um Ian has to pee and you but it's five
o'clock anyways I believe you by the way
I'm being reminded of that Meme Dan when
that podcast is four hours instead of
three hours yeah by the way I want to
defend you Dan works so hard he's in
here early the man works his ass off
nobody has a right to accuse him of
being lazy
nobody
thank you thank you thank you that being
said that Meme was very funny
I I you're talking about the Reddit
posts yeah yeah yeah Arthur I wasn't I
didn't need defending I thought it was
funny yeah it was funny
all right so you're telling me wrap it
up wrap it up I could have gone down
that [__] for a minute I know
about to take I'm not this is your last
shot streamies this is it
we're all coming
and if I don't win
I'm just saying there's enough of us
We Roll deep
there's enough of us to do something oh
my God all right
thank you for watching Everybody we'll
see what are you doing see you next
Tuesday tomorrow yeah what time
let me see if I have something random
time
well it does it shifts almost every week
so I just want to let the people
tomorrow I have
oh open hype
Oppenheimer wait what why is there two
open timers live streaming openheimer
yeah uh tomorrow at uh I don't know one
one o'clock or two or twelve or twelve
no I'll do it at one I'll do that one
one o'clock will Tweed when we're live
see you all there bye love you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]